all right and we
are live the last word with lore cognito
and ebatis
special edition sunday night campfire
nice little special guest little
pre-launch action e what's going on man
uh it has been uh there's so much
going on it's been kind of crazy but we
are on the cusp of
kind of the next era of destiny it's
it's a big deal there's a lot to talk
about a lot to discuss and a lot of hype
but we have an awesome gentleman waiting
in the wings so
let's let's get him in here the only way
we know how
bring him in welcome to the last word
episode
127. what a week it has been
and what a week that lies ahead as we
wrap our third year on destiny 2
and our sixth in the franchise we
couldn't have a better guess joining us
tonight to celebrate the launch of the
next expansion
and the start in death in the start of
the new trilogy
in destiny's universe our guest tonight
is a renaissance man for sure
his gaming journey started with flying
games joysticks dogfighting and all
it seems like that interest was deeper
than just gaming though as he is now a
real
live pilot hashtag please take me to
guardian con
whether whether it be his time
underwater as an experienced scuba diver
or taking another go at the lynx this
man is no doubt a man of many talents
his gaming history also includes
strategy games which of course
it matched his analytical nature and of
course
like many he was on red red alert at
some point in his times
he first tried halo through a demo and
it was then he knew he wouldn't be the
same
since then it's been a love affair of
first person shooters in bungie games so
you know destiny was inevitable
so i'd like to introduce a man who is
known as a raid boss in early season
iron banner
a crucible sandbox analyzer master of
cones
forsaken gameplay specialist destiny
content creator
contributor from reddit to pc gamer
co-host of the massive breakdown podcast
mr high risk high reward the one the
only
spreadsheet man himself mercury's how
are you doing sir
oh my god that was a hell of an
introduction i don't know
but i haven't ever been introduced that
way before but i like it i'm gonna try
it
i'm gonna need to record that and start
playing it before i walk into business
meetings from now on
you're good the audio will be up later
you can take it yeah like you guys don't
know who i am but yeah
i like that i like that i appreciate it
man i'm happy to be here thank you guys
for having me on the podcast i'm looking
forward to talking about some destiny
absolute pleasure van i mean big time
fan i know
all of us would try to get this schedule
together to make it happen so it
actually worked out really good
pre-launch you know what i mean right
before but uh first of all like how you
been man i mean
just in general we i know we talked
briefly about getting ready for destiny
but like
how how excited are you and then um just
in general you know what i'm saying
how you been i mean i'm stoked i think
this is the biggest thing
that's probably ever happened to destiny
i mean i know taking king
was like a hard reset forsaken was a
hard reset both those things were huge
but um this is this is the next
generation of testing right because we
know that they're not going to do a
destiny 3 anymore so
this is going to show us what they plan
to do with destiny 2. and like you said
it's a new trilogy
um i'm excited about it i think this is
going to be huge and
and thankfully the foundation that
they're building on is pretty solid now
after a couple years of working on it i
feel like they've gotten the game to a
good place
so i'm really just super stoked for it
and i've been playing a ton even though
i barely have any time to actually do it
like i'm still
i'm playing on all my characters i'm
working out my titan which i have i
barely have done at all like i'm a
hundred main
uh obviously you know master rays but
yeah i've been i've been working the
titan out i've been working the warlock
out i've been
trying all the different cheese
strategies like you guys said raid boss
and iron banner man i got that uh i got
that ariana's bound and empowering rift
one shot going on
upset people with shotguns is like my
forte so if i can
use a bastion and piss some people off
then i'm good to go so
my prep basically is like how can i ruin
everyone's day in pvp
on day one of this new expansion yeah
december 8th i think it is on the
schedule stay
out of iron banner this man is going to
be running rampant
that's what's up man unless you want to
get into this little history
with this with the legendary merc
seriously man you have quite a history
from
like i gotta ask like you started
obviously playing games i mean i
played some like you know joystick games
and stuff and played like the old top
gun and things like that on a joystick
and obviously you did as well how in the
world did you go from
was it just like did anybody else have
any influence to take you from like
a flight sim combat dog fighting game to
actually be get like your pilot's
license and be a pilot like how did that
go from one side to the other like his
fight well my dad was actually a pilot
and my granddad was a pilot so i'm
actually a third generation pilot in my
family so
i was always probably going to be a
pilot anyways but
it just happened that because i grew up
around so much aviation related
uh stuff that the first games that i
took to were flight simulators
my dad's actually the one who bought me
my first game which was a flight
simulator it's called dawn of aces it's
like a very very old
game that like i mean if you guys ever
look up the graphics it's crazy like how
old that game looks now but
like that was my first game and he
bought me a joystick and he bought me
the game because i was you know
single digit ages obviously couldn't fly
an airplane for myself so
then you know as soon as i had the money
to basically afford it
because unfortunately flying is quite
expensive but as soon as i
was in college and i was working i saved
up a little bit of money and i could
afford it then i got my pots license so
nice nice that's pretty awesome man i
mean
you know being as you said you're coming
from that like whole generation of
family of pilots and stuff like that
like
it just to me it's like i always think
as a kid it would be daunting like at
that young early but
it almost seems like you kind of were
indoctrinated in that that culture as
far as just flying games and things that
nature
yeah it was normal to me right like
flying wasn't something to be scared of
or something that was intimidating it
was something that my granddad did and
my dad did and
obviously they had a bunch of friends
who were also pilots so to me it wasn't
ever something i looked at and i was
like oh that's
crazy that people do that to me it was
just something very normal it was like
driving a car to work like oh on the way
to go and you fly your airplane right
that was just what it was so
unfortunate to have been you know lucky
enough to be raised in something like
that where it was normal and it wasn't
anything crazier out there um so i'm
very thankful for that but yeah to me it
was just like
a thing mm-hmm not fair enough enough
speaking of which uh
how are you feeling about that new
microsoft flight simulator sir
dude i wish i had a computer i wish i
had a computer that could run that thing
on anywhere close to the highest
settings i think everybody wishes they
had a computer that could run it because
nobody can
i have like a i mean i don't have a
desktop pc anymore because
i just i do almost all my gaming on xbox
at this point in time
um i'm just more of like i like gaming
from the couch more so than i do like
gaming from a chair
so i know my gaming on xbox i got rid of
my last desktop that i've had and all
i've had since then are like they're
relatively high powered laptops because
i have to do
design work for my actual job but like
even these things struggle to run the
games on like the high fidelities
so yeah i got an xbox series s on
pre-order
and then for christmas i'm treating
myself to a 4k tv and a series x
okay so we're doing we're doing we're
doing that oled though right we're doing
that oled correct
yeah all right i'm gonna get i'm gonna
get the nicest thing i mean i'm i'm
moving all my tvs like i have a tv
in a guest bedroom i have a tv in an
office and i have a tv in the living
room and i'm like shifting them all up
room tv is going to my office the
current office tv is going to the guest
bedroom and then we're getting a new tv
for the living room so i'm free
what's going in the living room is going
to be the nicest tv that i can possibly
get at that point in time so
because i can hang on to it for like you
know a long time so
it's got to be top of the line right now
so it's not dated in a year
absolutely man get that 4k 120 that
variable refresh rate
you're going to be good to go man you'll
be rocking and rolling on that that's it
review slider on xbox now
oh my god oh it can't wait to know
so many people that are just console
gamers that truly don't know what's
coming
i'm yeah i'm waiting i'm waiting for
people's like reactions like
just completely dumbfounded the field of
view the 60 frames per second
destiny is a gorgeous game on like on pc
and like so many people are about to
experience and you got 4k oled you're
like 65-inch couch you're like um you
may as well just strap in for the roller
coaster ride it's
so crazy i knew because i was all xbox
but then when i went helped and actually
worked at bungie everything there was pc
right so like i went from playing on
that special player on pc
and like of course they have monster
rigs out there oh yeah as much as they
need and i was just like
oh no like this is going to be so hard
to go back to my xbox like i can't
afford it
what it basically amounts to two
thousand dollar like desktop
yup that's pre-built by the specialist
they have out there and like
it was like oh god man this is gonna be
hard and sure enough it was
like it was it's hard to go back to 30
fps which sometimes drops lower than
that on that
one or something and that's super
limited field of view that makes you
feel like you're like moving through
molasses basically
i thought it was my last respect yeah
dude
i mean i i realized how much you could
take advantage of having a wider field
of view like you can see it on xbox like
players lose track and pvp of other
players so easily
because you're just so narrowed in your
cone so small that like you sidestep or
do something and you can like see the
player like looking all over the place
that's why hunters especially as you as
a hunter on console you're like
terrifying for
most people i would say is because like
you jump up once and they're like
where is and you're dead and it's
yeah that's trouble so i i refuse to use
uh stompies
like i just flat out because i mean this
is a that's
this is a personal drawback of let's get
in but like i despise meta with just
like a burning passion like i
refuse to use anything that is meta
won't use blade dancer won't use
spectral blades won't you stop these
won't use shotguns won't use hand
cannons like
i just i don't like it man like i feel
you to me
part of the challenge of gaming is like
challenging yourself and all those
things just give you such a huge
leg up and such a huge advantage over
another stuff that i don't feel like
it's as challenging but granted that's
the type of player i am i'm not playing
the same way i was trying to get
flawless every single weekend like i'm
playing 66 because i think that's
actually where destiny's sandbox is at
it's best
when it's a little bit chaotic it's a
little bit imbalanced
and to me like using you know not
forgotten
and a shotgun and stompies on a blade
dancer
is just stacking the decks so far in my
favor that
i don't feel like it's fun to play that
way so i'm using the stuff that counters
all that stuff basically i'm using
an invis night stalker and a bastion and
bastion i've heard you talk about that
one that's one of those you're like just
just shut them down nobody listened to
me like a long long time ago like months
and months and months before
people started complaining about basking
i was talking about a massive breakdown
podcast and i was like
i tested it out i thought it was gonna
be garbage like y'all don't understand
it's incredibly good you gotta start
using it like you can shut down supers
you can crush shotgunners like
i literally think it's one of the
strongest guns in the game and nobody's
playing with it and then
months later now everybody talks about
how much they hate bastion
because you know it's like it's it's
just gone to a different point i was
like
i think it's safe for a little while
though so you at least get a little more
time to use it that's for sure
i would be kind of surprised if they
nerf bastian like the stuff that people
complain about a lot of times comes from
uneducation on the gun like
i hear people saying like oh the range
is crazy it's like nah aarontol and it's
nerfed state still has a longer range
than fasting by like several meters
like y'all y'all don't know what your
army the only thing that it has that's
actually strong is that it can shut down
supers
but i think that that's a problem with
how much damage does this supers have as
opposed to it being a problem with
fasting i think more
special weapons should be able to
counter supers yeah as opposed to
removing the only one that really can
because you know supers are still and
this is i love doing these comparisons
to destiny one but like destiny two
supers two
of a unit are infinitely stronger than
destiny one supers oh yeah
like it's not even close like destiny
one supers were like nova bomb
fist of havoc now it's like traveling
fist of habit with unlimited shoulder
charges
what it's like and you're like
they talk about power creep but like
that was the biggest power creep
they ever did and they still have not
the sandbox is still not recovered from
how strong they made
remix well that's like a top tree right
now oh my god yeah
it is it is strong that is terrifying
and that's why like you see a super pop
do you do whatever it's like i'm gonna
go hide
because it doesn't make much sense to do
much else at this point
if you're an amazing sniper or you run
bastian like this man
you got a shot but for bastian you still
would have to like bait him around a
corner and have it charged up and then
catch him right and make sure they don't
throw
you know fire sword in your face
basically it's not really a real shot
like
your only chance is pretty much team
shot them and hope that they're just
terrible at their super
which almost none of them are because
it's so easy to be good or
you know hope that you're great with the
sniper but they have so much mobility
even that's really hard i mean
yeah it's that's the one thing i still
don't like about destiny's sandbox is
that the
supers are so wildly overpowered right
now and like uh it's actually josh
hamrick no longer works at bungie but he
worked there when i was working there we
had a lot of conversations about this
but one of the things he said is like
if you have a win button right like the
win button needs to be super super
limited
so that was the problem that people had
in halo reach with uh armor lock
it was like it was a win button and it
was an easy to use win button it had a
lot of up time and a lot of utility and
lasted for a long time that's why people
didn't like it
that's why fist of havoc in d1 was a one
and done and that was it right
because it's a win button but like you
have to be pretty close to them and you
just like one shot
and like that's it same thing with nova
bomb the problem is you've got a bunch
of supers that are win buttons that last
for 30 seconds and can go
all the way across the map and back and
they're tanky and they're fast
and a lot of them like regen health on
kills so it's like yes
it's a win that's a win but in the last
seven times and that's a good point
and the problem is is for the player who
is using that like sure it's a ton of
fun
but from every player they kill it's not
very much fun because you feel like
there's nothing you can do you feel like
you're having right
so you end up making one player feel
like a god at the expense of potentially
making six players on the other team
feel like they're garbage and that's an
uneven balance basically so
well the other issue is you take
something like that where some of these
supers
the people who like pair the right
exotic with it have the right stats so
they get it up more frequently
and work with like even a medium-sized
team where they start sharing
supers and orbs it gets to be a vicious
cycle to where you're saying it's like
it's already a win button now you have a
win button that just cycles between
three or four people even more when they
start popping it
that's where especially as we're gonna
have a lot of new people coming into
beyond light for example
new lights getting the new experience
they're gonna be like oh what's this
holy hell what is crucible like that's
not even a
fair ball game when they jump in and
face somebody like who knows what
they're doing with a super in an exotic
that they don't have yet and they're
like
he the same guy killed me three times
with a super like that's hap that's
that happens that shouldn't happen i
know absolutely
to me and i'm a good player like it's
going to happen to new players and
unfortunately it's probably going to
turn them off a bit but
right you know there were decisions that
were made about the sandbox and what
they wanted to be
strong in the sandbox and they felt that
supers were one of the really enjoyable
parts of the game
like one of the really fun parts of the
game really unique part of the game so
they went all in on making them really
strong but i think it comes at the
overall detriment of the sandbox
now you make some good points i want to
double back a little on something you
said earlier in reference to the meta
and in reference to kind of picking
non-wet meta weapons or
counters to meta stuff and it really
resonates with me because
i'm the same way like it's almost like
everybody's doing that like i just can't
do
that like you know saying like it's it's
too easy to just fall in that box now
yeah granted if i get pissed off and
nothing's going on
maybe i might you know resort once in a
while but you feel dirty doing it like
i'm doing what these guys are doing but
yeah it's like one thing about destiny
that i really feel is like there's so
many hidden gems
that people think are not effective it's
just that they're not being utilized and
then
when you actually utilize them and you
strategize like what you were saying
with um bastion and other weapons
it you realize like yo these are still
powerful these are still
effective you know what i'm saying and i
know everyone gets caught up with time
to kill and
we get it but i i definitely feel what
you're saying in reference to
there are a ton of what i consider
sleeper weapons sleeper builds sleeper
classes that are not utilized as much
that people think
are not effective they're just going
it's just beelining to
a meta and you know time to kill kind of
stuff and there's still a lot of stuff
out there so salute on that because i
definitely
just gotta say shout out to like them
plays like
that is the man that will embrace the
yes what what is the
what is the super the warping warlock
yeah nova warp like he he will just make
people just
miss juke dodge he has so much i love
his clips that he'll put up because
nobody uses that one but that is like
that is his baby and he's mastered it
i'd love to see somebody take something
as you said
not meta and be like i'm still just
going to mess with your head with
something that you don't even see coming
which is even the best part because then
they're not even sure how to counter it
which is probably why at that time like
i've watched him do he's very good yeah
yeah he's actually really impressive
yeah it is shout out to that's we had
them on man that's good people
yeah man what have you got e uh i mean
for you
i just wanted to ask you kind of blew
past it a little bit but dude you got to
work at bungie
yeah it was humble flex it was cool i
was gonna say i
there's probably some stuff you can't
say but it was for it was for forsaken
correct
yeah pretty soon i worked on um we
worked on
forsaken specifically and then like
black armory was just getting started
when
i was uh headed out um most of the stuff
like the way the nda works is like i
obviously can't talk about any like
internal stuff
but the stuff that i was working on once
it went into the game
then i was allowed to talk about it
again so it wasn't like you know i'm
forbidden from ever speaking about
anything i talk about it a decent amount
on on my podcast as well and on
uh firing range and stuff like that you
know absolutely but it was an incredible
experience man like it was
for as long as i've been involved in
first-person shooters i always like
had the dream like every kid doesn't
like working at bungie
on like halo or destiny or something
like that and then to actually get the
call
and be like hey we want to offer you
this position was
like legitimately a dream come true i
could not believe it i was so stoked i
dropped everything that i was doing here
which is wow
actually you know really hard to do and
like went out there and worked on it and
it was every bit as amazing as you think
it'd be like all the people out there
super passionate about the game and they
really really love it there's a ton of
people who play the game super hardcore
uh at the studio and like we got
together in a group and
just played destiny all the time and
that's awesome
i had some awesome like these
discussions that we have where like i
argue about the meta and arguable stuff
like i was doing that
bungie with the people who were
designing the meta like the feedback
that i was giving was
like being directly worked on and like
the next day in the next building
we didn't see the results of some of the
stuff that we said like
you know some of the stuff they didn't
listen to me like i told him one eye
mask was going to be super broken
so i was like hardcore abusing it and
wave splitter too which i didn't realize
exclusive that broke my heart because
i'm next i was like super
abusing that in some of the play tests
and i was telling him and i was like
this is like
this is way over the top super good like
you guys just nerfed warm husk crown and
warmup crowd is nothing compared to what
this is going to be
and they were like well a lot of the
other play tests don't seem to have the
same opinion like some people think it's
too hard to activate it they don't see
it activate enough it's like well yeah
if you're like a
sub 1.0 kd player like you're not going
to see that
if you're terrible i'm getting 40 kills
a game which means i have
all 100 uptime on this like i constantly
have an overshield and tracking and
bonus damage like
i'm spending my entire game with an
overshield
this is awesome and they're like okay
well we'll see how it goes and then you
know
sure the same thing with wastewater too
i was like i can melt people with
wastewater like wastewater is
awesome oh yeah well we'll see so
some of the stuff you know uh but other
stuff too like we
we had a ton of good discussions just
about the way the game should feel and
about
certain you know weapons and playlists i
mean i probably played the forsaken
campaign i
legitimately believe from start to
finish like 24 times wow
like wow we played it uh super under
leveled
solo super over leveled solo at light
level solo outlet levels of three man
under levels of three man
overlapping levels of three man like so
we could get this huge like swath of
like
how does it feel and i told him like
flat out the most fun i ever had
playing pve solo in destiny was playing
that 30 light levels under that entire
campaign 30 light levels under and
locked 30 live levels under the whole
way
because it felt like every one of those
uh
adventures where you killed one of the
barons felt like a mini raid boss
because like you were so under level
that they could one or two shot you and
you had to learn
all their mechanics you had to learn all
their movements you had to learn all the
stuff
i spent two hours trying to kill the
machinist right wow
in the actual campaign is like in the
actual campaign it's like 10 or 15
minutes and it's like okay you kind of
figured out and then you're just like
done
and you like don't even realize that she
has like all these like this huge swath
of abilities that she uses depending on
what you're doing but you never realize
because in the campaign you're just like
kind of new girl because you're like
yeah that's a good but i was 30 light
levels under couldn't nuke her
was like scrounging for ammo like
equipping the best blues that i had to
try to
get into the thing it was like doing all
the stuff and i remember starting at
like
10 a.m and going all the way until lunch
and beating her like one minute before
his time like go to lunch and just being
like
yes i did it i did it
and it's like that's the type of
reaction of like i feel like you don't
really get in the story
and within this game at all for me it
was a freaking awesome experience like
a great memory that i have been working
out there so that that is awesome i mean
first of all salute because like you
said like dream come true kind of
position you know what i mean like and
to be able to stop what you're doing
head out there you know kind of change
your dream so to speak and also to be
selected right how does
how good does that feel right when when
you get the call it's like yo
because of what you're doing in the
community we feel
you're a good representative and who we
want testing our product
aka your favorite game so like how dope
is that
and then in general what i was going to
ask you was just like um
what do you think you know obviously
can't talk about what you can't talk
about but
just general generalization like what do
you think are kind of the biggest
misconceptions about bungie and the
sandbox that maybe most
of us gamers don't realize you know what
i mean that you go through
um i mean a lot of stuff like i
i really wanted to write a huge loan
post on reddit when i got back out and
deej actually told me
like nah like don't bring that on
yourself it's not worth it like
we don't need you to defend us as a
company we don't need you to defend us
as people like
we're fine on our own like don't write
anything because there are so many
misconceptions that are so just
egregious and like almost not even
almost they are insulting to the people
who like work on the game
like the first is like they're just
money growers they don't care about
people like they're just trying to steal
your money through eververse and stuff
like that like that's
so far from the truth and it is really
frustrating actually knowing and working
with the people who worked on eververse
and like how much they go out of their
way to try to make it a better
experience do they always get it right
like no of course not
right they don't always get it right
sometimes just frustrating sometimes it
feels like it's anti-consumer but it
never really is considering what it is
that they're doing
and how much worse it could be but
people are
i hesitate to say entitled because it's
not necessarily the right thing but like
people
think that they deserve a certain thing
from a company for a certain amount of
money and
right you know they're still a business
right like they have operating expenses
and they have cost and they have
stakeholders who care right but they're
not trying to screw us
as a consumer no they're just not trying
to do it the second thing is that they
think that nobody there like plays the
game and like they don't understand
the same it's so far from the truth the
same frustrations that we experience
like you could look at the top page of
reddit
and it would be the things that we would
be talking about in meetings
totally independently because we were
playing and a lot of people there
are playing and share the same
frustrations as the player base
and i'm trying to get things fixed but
there's so much stuff that goes on
behind the scenes like
sometimes things just can't be fixed
like sometimes things are really
complicated or the way they're broken is
in such a way that
it's like a house of cards and if you
pull out one thing to try to fix it
you're going to break a lot more stuff
and it's going to make the experience a
lot worse right
so there's a lot of misconceptions that
like bungie doesn't know what they're
doing or they're purposely trying to
screw stuff but they're not fixing bugs
because
they help the player instead of hurt the
player it's like you know
it's it's this whole unfortunate thing
and like
a lot of people were really hard on
people like emmy chung and luke smith
and stuff like people who were very
much the face of the destiny franchise
during that destiny reveal event like
there were some people who like put
themselves out there and like talked
about it
and because of various things they said
like that stuff got pulled out of
context and it
kind of got like vilified by the
community for a little bit of time and
like this was
you know this was forsaken this was a
couple years ago like this was when
destiny 2 had not
turned things around yeah yeah and was
doing badly it was spooky
yeah and people were just being really
really awful to like the people who
worked
on the game and it sucked to see that
like they see that stuff and like it
affects them and it's like
they're not living in a bubble with
their immune and the horrible things
people are saying about them on reddit
were just like
they resonated inside the studio and
they like legitimately made those people
like sad and like that's sad to see
right that people don't understand
what they're saying online like hurts
these people who are
trying to make the best game that they
possibly can for us to like enjoy but
you know it's the internet there's
always shitty people on the internet so
yeah you're right
you're right it's funny you said that
because my brief interactions
with deej i kind of pulled him to the
side
he after we we saw the um the
presentation at
uh at gcx and um i was just like man
i know we could be tough and ridiculous
sometimes i know
and he's like no man our job is to serve
the customer
and he was like you ain't got to he kind
of said the same thing like you got to
defend us you know say but i was just
like
i i know it because you know even you
know i have fallen real victim like yo i
don't understand
you know and it's like all they should
do is that it's not that easy you know
what i'm saying so
you got to have empathy you got to
understand what they're going through
and again like you said they're humans
you know they see everything like we see
you open up reddit and
you know you see all your game sucks and
this but what the key that i always tell
gamers
don't personalize it know how to
get your construction constructive
criticism out in a way
where you're not being disrespectful you
know what i'm saying and didn't
verbalize your point the correct way but
i feel what you're saying definitely
yeah they told us the best way because
we even had that issue when we went out
there like none of the three of us were
developers in the sense of like we're
game developers like i work in software
development
holtzman had worked in software
development before like modding and
stuff like that but not like direct
development i'm
i mean i guess technically the
comparative term for bungie would be a
producer so like i don't actually
directly code i
run the dev teams that do all the actual
work right but
so i'm around them and i see how it's
going right but even i had to like
learn how to provide feedback in a
certain way out there to them and what
they said is like
the best type of feedback you can give
is a specific example like
this made me feel this way like
this action or inaction made me feel
unhappy sad frustrated like putting the
game down like turning the game off blah
blah blah
what i was expecting was this what i
would have preferred was this stuff like
that but like don't tell them how to do
that
right just say like uh this
weapon dropping uh didn't make me feel
happy
because it felt like it was unearned i
would have preferred had i earned it
from
this right and then let them work the
back end to how to get
to that preferred feeling or how to get
to that preferred action as opposed to
you telling them
i think you should do it this way
because that doesn't necessarily work so
i learned a lot about that and like the
first couple weeks we were out there we
even
you know we had to have meetings with
like leadership team be like okay how do
we give this feedback to this
development team that
very much like were game players and
their game developers like how do we
bridge the gap between the two of us so
we're not
so they don't feel like we're ready
yelling at them yeah and we don't feel
like they're ignoring us and ignoring
our feelings and ignoring our feedback
so we
were able to bridge that gap
successfully and i think we made a lot
of really positive changes to the game
by we i mean the entire team working on
forsaken not us because we all we did
was just give feedback but
the team that was working on forsaken
made some incredible changes and some
incredible refinements like even up to
like the 11th hour like
you know because what happens is the
thing goes to cert and so they
stopped working on it you know x amount
of days before it goes live but then
they're working on the day one patch
right and like they're immediately doing
that like there was no break there was
no stopping it was just
like we already know these things are
gonna be a problem we're gonna get it
out for the day one patch it was
really incredible to see so i wanted to
ask you actually and that's kind of one
of those things we've talked about
before
and i feel like i've seen it and we've
kind of joked
destiny is a very specific game because
we've talked about this like the unique
way
weapons feel and it's the feeling you
get from the weapons that you use in
destiny kind of gives people attachment
to them they get a hold of them sunset
makes them like question like what's
going on
but on the other side we also have like
the idea that bungie is so so so
data-driven
and i was just kind of curious if you
almost got to see both sides of that
because you literally said it yourself
you're like how does this make you feel
so it's like
some of that you can't quantify but on
the other side like we know they have
their data they change like a
auto rifle percentage by like .01 damage
and stuff like that
i was just kind of curious how you if
you can even explain and you may not be
able to
but just how it felt to be like how the
feel
versus like the data and how they kind
of made both of those work
no i the amount of data they have on the
back end that they collect
is actually insane it was the most
impressive thing
that i've like ever seen what they can
collect from players right
you get you get a hint of it when you
look at uh websites that scrape the api
like destiny tracker and stuff like that
where you can say
average kill distance and crit
percentage right but the way they are
able to combine all that to make like a
profile for player types
and then the way they can break it down
by the weapons they use the subclasses
they use
like everything it's so incredible what
i would say
is that i feel like a lot of the
decisions they make are
i feel this way let's look at the data
and see if the data backs up that
statement
right gotcha i feel like this gun is
overpowered
and overused let's go look at the data
and see if the data backs up the fact
that it does kill faster and that it
it's getting a disproportionate amount
of kills right so i think the way they
use the data is
is very very uh safe and very smart i
don't think that
necessarily that a lot of their at least
sandbox wise i didn't feel like a lot of
the decisions they made sandbox wise
were data-driven
first it was this is what i feel we
should go look at the data and see if
this is the case or if it's just an
isolated incident
right i wish personally that i had
access to all their data because
like there are a lot of things that
people complain about
that i would love to be able to point to
the data i'd be like nope like flat out
wrong
and the reason why i can say that stuff
is because i look at as many of the
numbers as i can before i draw a lot of
my conclusions right like
i will complain about the fact that like
oh like during the luna's hal thing like
oh i feel like i'm being killed by lunas
how a lot well
luna's house make up like 67 primary
kills despite the fact that it was owned
by like you know
less nervous
something is clearly actually incorrect
about this like this is
not a healthy place for it to be but
then you have people who are complaining
about bastian to use the example we've
already
been on and they're like oh bastion is
overpowered
because it has ridiculous range well no
it doesn't and if you actually
looked at the numbers you would know
that it doesn't have ridiculous range
right or
basting is uh way too used it's
super highly used the highest level it's
like no it's not bastion accounts for
literally like less than one percent of
all special weapon kills and it's like
it's it's really not right like you guys
have to look at the numbers what you're
doing is you're going on twitter and
writing complaining about something that
because it's based on your feel right
but you're not taking the second step
which bungie does
which is say okay you think bastion's
overpowered well let's look at the data
the
data
doesn't share that same opinion now that
doesn't necessarily mean that like
you can't touch something because
sometimes like feel like you know like
herbalist right now right
i personally think that our bliss is way
too strong right that's a feeling
the numbers and the usage numbers don't
necessarily support that at this exact
point in time
however due to the nerf to low zoom
sniper rifles i think they're going to
start supporting that more
and so like you can preemptively make a
decision that the data doesn't
necessarily support
um but you know and some of the time i
would do that like you know just because
arvolus is going to be obviously going
to be holding it maybe i'll be wrong
maybe
honestly no i think honestly arbales is
one of those ones that we don't we never
got to see much of it
the main time we did is when komodo was
there and you saw everybody was like i
have to find a way to get komodo
i don't get this that often there's a
special the times that i got shot but
also some of the shots that i hit
with that gun should never have happened
i should have hit the post the jaguar
sign on your wall
not even been near your head and then i
turned out i'm like
i'll take the kill because i know i'm
going for the quest but i was like i'm
pretty sure that was just trash if i
would
roll back the footage and i would just
be like yeah no and that's one of those
i think you even
yeah the aim assist on that what'd you
say because i think i listened to it
recently how high is the aim assist on
that
it's not even necessarily if the aim is
stat is high it's that they went into
the back end and they monkeyed with the
actual aim assist like
value itself so like numerically it has
a very high aim as a stat
but it's that the zoom is super super
low and the actual aim assist cone for
linear fusion rifles got buffed right
so i don't know how many i've assumed
there's some overlap between your
listeners and like firing ranges
listeners but there's actually a cone
around the reticle that is basically the
bullet magnetism distance
that is like so your reticle's right in
the center but you know you can be
aiming
here next to my head and still hit me
because it's within the aim assist count
yep cause they actually took the ames
cone for linear fusion rifles and like
blew it out right now
and then what happens is when you zoom
in on something that cone compresses
based on a factor of the zoom so the
higher your zoom
the more that cone compresses and it
gets brought down to a very small amount
right
because otherwise you'd have super high
zoom weapons with these huge aim
assistants and
they would be like you know you
literally wouldn't even be able to see
the person's head because you're zoomed
in so far and you get a headshot right
and so
obviously they can't do that so the
problem with arbolus is that the zoom is
really really low it's like slightly
higher than scout rifles
so you have a weapon that kills like a
sniper rifle
with a huge aim assist cone and like
scout rifle zoom
and it's going to end up being just like
no land beyond the same thing happened
to no land beyond where nobody was using
it and then other stuff got nerfed
and all of a sudden people started using
it and they realized like oh wait this
is
really easy to use yep and it's going to
be the same thing with our list
i i think you're on to something because
remember e like we like you said with
komodo right right yeah it felt
really yeah i remember i was like okay
what i'm gonna use i'm like all right
let me dust off arboles
and i'm like yo this is really good like
like it was super easy to get this like
those kills but continue yo
i'll cut you off yeah i mean it's that's
pretty much what it is like people are
going to start using
it and they're going to be like oh man
this is yes
like people didn't use it because we got
gifted revoker and then we got gifted
yeah uh beloved like these super low
zoom snipers revoker had a crazy amount
of aim assist because again
low zoom so people started using our
broker and they were like well
this doesn't have a charge time well the
charge time for arboles is less than
half a second
so yeah when you start hearing that
thing fall around a map and you're on
like convergence or something like that
you're like
it's gonna be a long match and you can't
counter it because the way flinch works
there's just you can't counter it with a
primary at least you can counter it if
you're a good sniper you can counter it
and that's why arbelis doesn't use a
tremendous amount right now because
there's a lot of people using revoker
or brokers are hard countered to
arbalest but broker is going to be
sunset
and no zoom snipers are going to be
nerfed so
you know the next thing you're going to
have is i guess uh eye of soul is going
to be probably the next best sniper
rifle or maybe
twilight oath cool guy has anything to
say about it you got borealis
yeah borealis is actually borealis is
really good too
cool guy and i've talked about that but
i mean he's correct that it is an
aggressive sniper rifle with the stats
of a rapid fire sniper rifle which high
aim assist
big mag size you know it's a great
sniper
but it's an exotic and the exotic perk
is relatively useless so
yeah yeah i agree i just um
if you've got anything yet i got a
question go go yeah you're good no i
want to shout
mark out because how i actually came
across you i mean this is like
you know i'm just getting into destiny
d1 you know
i'm messing around you know i jump into
trials i get a little bit of the fever
for it
and i'll never forget because the main
reddit was always destiny the game
you know what i'm saying and i was just
like man okay this is cool
but i started evolving into a pvp guy
not that i was great but i was
the most average pvp guy but i just
started
getting a feel for it and i remember
people talking about
crucible playbook and i'm like okay all
right let me check it out
and i remember man i would be on this
thing
every day and i would see this mercury's
name
and i would be like all right and he you
would just have stuff
either predictions about what's gonna
happen or what you think would be good
in the meta
time to kill and it was so useful and
it's so funny when i met you because i'm
like yo this is the dude like i bet you
at gcx we had a drink you don't remember
but
at the end we were probably drunk but at
the end of the day i was just like it
was so
important because as a pvp guy
the thing that people don't realize is
like again all these weapons
all these stats what's actually
effective you know what i'm saying
and the way you guys the way you broke
it down was pretty cool so i want to
shout you out for that number one
and two like how did that whole just
getting entrenched with like crucible
playbook like how did that really start
for you
um well i was a reader there before i
was a poster there
i used to follow ex troopers or xx
trooper however you want to call it he
did the original
weapon stat spreadsheet and he actually
i think is still around crucible
playbook um
a decent amount i see him comment every
once in a while uh but he
did the original weaponstats spreadsheet
that had all the time to kill stuff on
it
um but he i guess he got busy in real
life or something and it stopped getting
updated as regularly and i was like
every new patch would come out i would
like wait for the updates and be like
okay cause like my thing
in d1 was like i want to find the
primary weapon that kills the fastest
fastest
i don't care what it is and like i'm
gonna use it because i'll figure out how
to like make that work into my game
right
so i would like wait for like the
updates and then what eventually
happened is it got slow and slow to
update and it also kind of got bloated
and which mine is getting bloated right
now too so i'm actually gonna have to go
through and i'm gonna cut it down before
beyond light comes out but um which is
tomorrow vegan
the online comes out you know tuesday
but basically i have tomorrow to now fix
it
yeah tomorrow's gonna be a busy day for
me but yeah um i
just started thinking like well
i'd probably be faster for me to just do
this myself instead of like waiting for
him to do it at this point time because
i
got to the point where it's like i don't
even know if he's going to come back and
do this anymore and i didn't want to
start with his spreadsheet because at
that point it's almost harder to like
manage someone else's work that is just
build your own so i just built my own um
and i posted it and then a bunch of
people came back and were like hey it'd
be nice if you
started doing this start doing this and
then people would come to me and they
would ask me like
hey i see on your spreadsheet that it
has this like what are the recommended
perks
for this gun that has this ttk and then
i would like write up a post and send it
to him
and then i started doing it for myself
and i would like basically
look at a gun and like make notes and be
like okay
i don't want to have to go to planet
destiny db
every single time i want to find it so
i'm going to make a little note for
myself
that's like this is the gun here it
stats and here's the recommended rule so
that whenever
i got a weapon to drop i could just look
at like my list and be like okay here's
the recommended rules for it
then i was like why am i writing this
for myself and not sharing it with
anyone so
then i just started posting it and it
originally was just the role guide it
didn't have like any
it had like stats in the recommended
roles and that was it and then people
were asking so many questions about why
do you recommend these roles
and i started putting the little blurbs
underneath them
now it takes me a ton of time and effort
to like write those things up and so
it's like now i don't do them nearly as
much as i just don't have the time
anymore but
that's pretty much how it happened i
mean it was just i was making something
for myself because i wanted to use it
and then it didn't make sense just like
not share it with everyone
and then the same thing with the role
guides like i was doing that for myself
because i wanted to use them and again
it just made sense to share with
everyone so
the massive breakdown like handle that
tag just
literally became because the the very
first one of those i wrote
was something like 40 000 words long
like this
ridiculous like huge thing and i
literally
like the title was massive breakdown
because i wanted people to understand
like what you're about to get like a
wall of texas
oh yeah and so i put massive breakdown
in the title and then someone in the
comments
you know was like hey but thanks for the
warning
or something like that that's awesome
i'll just start putting that on
everything else
here's my dissertation on a gun and
they're like okay here we go
yeah i mean i tracked it when i applied
at bungie so i got uh someone who
reached out to me and said hey you
should apply for this shop we think it'd
be good for you
so i applied for the job and when i was
building my resume
i like went back and i counted up all of
maybe
all of the stuff that i had written and
it was something like
almost there's like 450 pages worth of
destiny content and it was
hundreds of thousands of words oh yeah
right and it was like
i like looked up i was like it was
equivalent to like a doctoral thesis
basically
on like destiny weapons yeah that's
that's pretty that's pretty strong
resume territory for a game play
specialist would be like
here's my doctorate and they're like oh
you came prepared you're like yeah i
know more about this than half of you
guys
yeah we qualified hamrick told me he was
like like we have an internal tool that
we use like track the ttk and everything
he's like honestly most of the time we
just have your spreadsheet up and he's
like wow
right about everything because he's like
your resiliency estimations like
they they their resiliency is like not
rounded to or their resiliency
is and the way they do all numbers is
different than the way the numbers are
actually displayed in the game right
like it displays like a rounded number
in the game and they actually in the
back end use the real numbers right
so he's like so you're going off
everything rounded numbers so he's like
some of your stuff is a little
you know it's not exactly but he's like
most of the time we'll just have like
your spreadsheet up and we'll just use
that because it's like it's easier and
faster to just
look at it and then go for it
i was about to say it's like when you
heard that you're like i mean yeah i'd
probably just like
flush and be like cool thanks
like voice crack moment like okay thank
you it was pretty awesome
josh josh was uh josh was a really cool
guy he's probably one of the people
we've worked with most closely
while we were out there he's very it was
kind of his thing was the sandbox right
yeah he was actually in charge of it
like josh yeah
he was the lead lead sandbox designer um
he was there during reach as well
um and we got into many many long
discussions about bloom
and things like that yeah
it was it was cool man like i really
enjoyed working with those people and i
felt like learning from some of the best
people in the industry
well obviously wasn't just saying there
are a lot of people there john
wisniewski and claude jerome and
with some of you guys yeah yeah those
guys are over at probably monsters now
so
yeah it's funny you said that yeah one
of my other guys is over there too and i
was telling them
one of my guys from my dead labs and
makes another game on state of decay
and when i saw their lineup and i'm like
oh they got whis newskey oh they cooking
something over there nice whatever
probably boss is doing i don't mean to
blow y'all up but y'all cook it up
something nice cause y'all got talent
i've seen that roster man yeah it's like
real impressive the amount of people
they've got over there it's
it's almost it's not almost all it's a
lot of ex bungie people though and it
was founded by
the old ceo of bungie so oh yeah yep
yeah so they're they're gonna be killing
it whenever they actually whatever game
they're releasing gonna be killing it
but um
absolutely there there's still some
great people left to bungee too like
victor
you guys actually saw in the most recent
uh vidoc and
and greg pang is over there still too
although i think he might be doing
something else now
but they're all great people it was
awesome i would like go to lunch and
just like sit down like talk with these
guys about the guns
and they'd be like well why do you think
this why do you think this one's like
well the numbers say this and they're
like
do that i mean like
are you sure about that i'll be like uh
let me go check like
so they're calling you out and you're
like crap i don't know
yeah it was fun man i really really
really enjoyed that like i
was though i got so deep into the
numbers and stuff out there like i was
sitting at the office testing stuff in
private
matches like finding shots to kill and
like finding range drop-offs and like
all this stuff and it was
it was a freaking blast those guys are
all geniuses i have a lot of respect for
how well they build the sandbox
considering how many moving parts there
are
that's kind of one of the biggest things
is like everybody
want to forget what it was it was wither
horde
and there was a point where you could
break wither horde's damaged tick by
switching over to mountaintop and i was
like
that alone tells me it's like there's so
much going on on the back end that is
not clear to all of us be like
because like the projectile now that's
ticking is based on what's actually in
your inventory not it was fired from i
was like
yeah their code is yeah i was like they
have put something together and it's
like as you said it is kind of a house
of cards though i remember and i think
the one you
like at least made it pop in my head the
house of cards was when they're trying
to flint
fix snipers i don't know if it was like
the flinch to snipers
and they it took a really really long
time for them to fix something because
like
what they thought it was wasn't that and
they were trying to dig through the code
to figure out but not break it
completely
now like from the from what you got to
see and just the respect for that you
have for them is like it's on a
different level from what all of us
who already like the game anyway it's
like you got to see you know behind the
scenes and just like yeah they're
they're scientists to a whole different
level yeah and
they're working on one of the most
complicated you know
things ever like they've built a world
and they built all the rules in the
world
and they built everything that we can do
and like it's just
the amount of people working on
something like it it blows my mind that
we even get games
like there is no reason on earth that we
should be getting games as complicated
as complex as destiny and having them
work
so smoothly when we do and that we can
enjoy playing them it's just like you
look at
the level of complexity and how much it
changed from even like
halo 3 which is still like a relatively
complex game comparatively but then you
look at how much
different destiny is and it's like they
just bit off a whole oh yeah yeah they
just bit off so much more
and it's amazing that it works as well
as it does it doesn't get enough credit
and i'll say it again and again because
at the end of the day
let's just look at exotic weapons
on their own and and how like something
for example like ruinous effigy you know
that drops this ball
then you can create this thing and you
know look at where the horde
all these sandbox morphing and changing
things and all these systems that kind
of overlap
and now have to play nice with each
other with other weapons you know what
i'm saying like it's
really complex and they don't get enough
credit man
and the the creativity right the
creativity of some of these things like
it is truly amazing man i gotta salute
the team for that like it is
that to me there's just no that's why
i'm so addicted to it like there's no
game like it
and then i'll match that with this
amazing gun play you know in this great
cooperative experience and then you have
destiny
we're still here six years yeah
seemingly you know every game that comes
out they're like oh this is going to be
the one thing that competes with destiny
yeah there's just like a floor littered
with the dead bodies of
anthem and avengers and you know right
now it's pretty much it's warframe
it's borderlands and i don't know if
there's room in this ecosystem for
anything else because between those
three games you pretty much have every
base covered
so good luck anyone out there who's
trying to build it well and i think
that's why
some games are finally trying to not do
the live service because like a godfall
it is a
it has a starting to finish it may have
an end game but there's a point where
you're going to hit it in
outriders that look like it's coming up
is going to be more of a story game
but there's going to be loot and stuff
involved and i think people are like
the amount of effort as you said it
takes to do a live service game on top
of anything else you're going to but the
continual support
people are seeing like yeah this is we
just got to do a game we can't keep
supporting forever and i think that's
one thing destiny's the only one at this
point is they're so far
they're so vested in it already six
years in they've learned a lot they've
got the systems they've got the
plan to it everything else is i think
tried and failed as you said but
and that's why i'm seeing like games
that are like yeah this is not a live
service yeah this is not a live service
and people like destiny you can have it
yeah yeah i mean if i were to build a
game i wouldn't build a live service i
don't think it's
i think the risk reward is
i think the risk is incredibly high and
the reward even if
you do it incredibly well is still yeah
the ecosystem is just
it's like i hate to say it's but it's
like trying to build
uh it was like trying to build an arena
shooter at the height of halo
right or at the height of call of duty
or trying to build a battle royale
at the height of fortnite like actually
a couple people
are able to do it and like apex legends
was able to do it and
right but it's it's you're you're
wading into the ring with these big dogs
that are like
ready that have you know huge
populations built in
that it's hard to pull them away those
people aren't necessarily looking for
something else right
so yeah i would i would not
envy any any group that tries to decide
that they want to go toe to toe
and people got to understand it's also
the timing
of when these things are released in
conjunction with you know people forget
like destiny almost didn't exist like
the trials and tribulations that these
games go through
to to get to where they go so it's like
destiny lucked out remember how many
things describe i mean we're at the
point now
where destiny's at that point now we're
getting a lot of what the original
vision
and things that were intended to be in
destiny during their like scrounge phase
in
in d1 when they were just kind of
pasting things together story-wise and
just getting the things out they've had
so many
if you've read uh what is it uh jason
schreier's book the blood sweat and
pixels
in reference to um the the origins of
destiny
i mean this game bit like it almost
didn't come out like so many times
yeah it's so many shifts and so many
metamorphosis it's just it's it's
amazing that destiny is here in the form
that is
so again you look at that and then you
look at other lunar shooters and i think
what it is is like what mark said is
they look at
the success of destiny now and everybody
wants to copy it
but it is not easy it is not easy and it
might not even be you know lucrative to
even jump into that and just kind of do
your own laying
to be honest as far as the live service
stuff yeah i mean if i had to build a
game i'd build an
arena shooter right now like that's an
empty spot in the ecosystem
right it kind of is honestly call of
duty has bought into the battle royale
thing
and that's where they're focusing all
their attention and the reason people
like battle royales is because
this is my opinion but i believe it's
speed i believe but
the reason people like battle royales is
because the reward
for winning is so so incredible right
you are the last one standing at a 50 or
out of 100 right
but the penalty for losing is almost
negligible unless you're like one of the
final few people
which most a majority of players aren't
right so majority of players drop in and
get killed with them first like few
minutes a game and then they just
immediately drop when they start another
game
right so there's almost no penalty for
dying
which a majority of players do but the
possibility of winning
is like the thing that keeps players
coming back and coming back
it's a really really brilliant idea it's
like the carrot is so
big and basically it's a gold painted
carrot at that point
that it's so appealing to go for it and
as you said the downtime especially as
they're smart enough to be like they as
long as the population's there
they get these matches up and you're
like your dad will go in you wait a
minute in the lobby bam you're flying in
it's like
as you said it doesn't have as much now
some people if they die every single
time first time
yeah like may not but for the most
people who fall in that like
anywhere from 10 to 40 that if the
average person gets in that realm
they get a decent game they get the
attention everybody starts fresh so you
always feel like you're on a level
playing field
as opposed to like a world of warcraft
or even like
even destiny is kind of daunting for
some people to jump into well it's like
well you have like
70 exotics and weapons that i don't even
have yet you've got these god rules
for them it's always a level playing
field the god the battle royale start
over every time so
it is always kind of a unique thing yeah
that's the the joy
of uh of a destiny looter shooter but
compressed down into
a 20-minute game like a 20-minute match
it's a really really
smart idea but you this the stuff you
see happen like pub g was the first
right or i guess not necessarily first
it was the first one that really blew up
and did it big
and then fortnite copied it and made it
easier and like more
arcadey and like that's exactly the same
thing that happened with halo and then
call of dude
like halo was there and halo had a crazy
skill
gap where like if you were bad and you
got matched against a good player you
weren't gonna get a center kill like it
just wasn't gonna happen
and call of duty saw how many people
were enjoying that even though they
sucked at the game
and they said what if we took the first
person shooter and we made it easier
right exactly what fortnite did to pub g
what if we took them
around yeah easier right and then that's
when you get the huge crowd
and all those people come in because
they loved halo but they sucked at halo
they loved pokemon they sucked at it
well now there's fortnight
a lot easier to be good at that game
right as long as you keep the population
high you keep those people happy so
that's what we did it was great but i
think i think the time is right for
another arena shooter to come in
and uh and kind of not everyone likes
the battle royale style
like they're i mean i personally don't
particularly enjoy the battle royal
style like
i i find it i find it tiresome
after a couple of games um because once
you get out of the point where you're
dying in the first couple minutes well
then you start getting to the point
where you're surviving for a good long
duration
of the game and then a death starts to
really have a negative effect
right then it starts to not be very much
fun where it's like if you don't win
well now i feel like i've wasted 20
minutes right or potentially
more so right yeah last point i'm making
i know we went on this long
but um i think for me i also struggle
with
progression because yes the thrill is
great
you know chicken dinner last minute
amazing love the concept amazing
you know people on the island you know
last-minute standing
but then it's like okay for that the
reward is what
right there's really no reward but
except cosmetic
and that's why i struggle with with that
because it's like okay
it's a tough balance because if you do
give me something that makes me better
then it becomes disproportionate right
and then the rich keep getting richer so
i understand
why it is but after a while the appeal
of a new jacket
is not going to make me keep playing
pump you don't say pubg and that's where
it wears off for me
yeah yeah it's the thrill of the single
match or if you
want that progression of a character
it's like yeah they're definitely very
different
for what you're going for for sure but
it's what's happening with trials right
now i mean it's really the exact same
thing right like it's
a majority of people don't ever feel
like they're gonna get flawless in
trials
and unfortunately the charles reward
system is in such a poor place that they
just
stopped playing which is why the trials
ecosystem is collapsing on itself right
now
even the people who do go flawless all
the time are starting to get to the
point like
why is it worth it for me to continue to
do this and so you've got both extremes
breaking off
and it's collapsing the ecosystem and
that's why trials are struggling so hard
and unfortunately i don't think adept
weapons is going to be
is going to be the thing that that jump
starts it i think they
need to this probably isn't what we were
trying to talk about this episode i
think charles needs a
complete overhaul from what it is like
first off card based matchmaking is a
terrible system
for trials
that they started to kill trials in d1
when they introduced card-based
matchmaking
because the whole point so i'm not
saying skill-based matchmaking is the
way to do it because it's not that's
actually the worst type of matchmaking
for trials right
but connection based matchmaker is the
only way to do it the reason being is
because an average player
with connection based matchmaking if
they play enough we'll get
lucky and get a card against not very
good people
and they will go flawless and there is a
chance
a chance that chance decreased as you
decrease some skill
but there's a chance that every player
if they played enough could get lucky
and could go flawless
right now the only way a not very good
player is going to get flaws is that
they get carried
and that's not fun for a lot of players
a lot of players don't want to do that
right and so what they basically made it
with card based matchmaking is they
basically made it a guarantee to where
the last couple of matches you're going
to play good people which means that for
average and below average players
they're never going to win the last
couple matches
so for a lot of players there's no
reason for them to play
trials because they're never going to go
flawless and the reward system is so
broken
that it's not worth it for them to go in
and play three games or something like
that either so
yeah what do you feel about i don't know
i'm sorry no and that's like
that's kind of the thing where you said
you don't even think a depths are and
honestly that's my worry as well
is because i know the adepts are going
to give a bit of a stat roll
and this is my worry when it comes to
when they've talked about nightfall
adept weapons as well
if this is what i'm looking into as i i
was stupid enough to do the conqueror
gauntlet in 24 hours
i had some help with that uh for sure
but
even going through that and i was like i
want to do it for the seal because i
don't know what it's going to be like
post sunsetting
all that stuff so i was like i wanted to
check that box but even as i was going
through it
i got some currencies and i got quite a
few exotics to drop
like some more okay rolls some were
trash but there was nothing to set it
apart
and if the only thing that i'm now
strike exclusive loot would be nice if
there's some weapons in there
but then in turn if like if this is the
same thing where it's like hey these
adept weapons they have
slightly better stats i'm sitting there
going for a grand master or a trials run
which both are like not easy to do
because not everybody does grandmasters
trials is still probably harder than
even grandmasters
but either way it's like that carrot if
it's just like slightly better stats
versus you know we still don't know
where the state of cheating is
as you said like you're still going
against if i end up playing against
somebody like you in trials just because
you're getting hype in the card oh i
made it to round five
mercury's made it two okay i may as well
just go ahead and hand him the win
as opposed to just a random group of
people as you said the connection base
honestly for that sounds
i never thought about it but that
actually sounds perfect but the carrot
has to be there too
like the matches the randomness of the
matches has to give some people
incentive
but also again it's still gonna get some
tense competition
like insane moments and if the if the
adept weapons are still just like little
bit of stats
i'm kind of worried as you said how much
it's gonna do they had they had trials
in a good place
like five years ago and they went away
from it when trump was no reason
for no reason it was connection based
matchmaking and they had bounties
that were play bounties right you could
get a gold tier reward from a play
bounty
didn't matter how bad you were you would
eventually get that gold tier reward
every week and the worse you were the
more you had to play to get that gold
tier roll
but you'd still get it right they went
away from that system both the
matchmaking system and the reward system
and trials population started decreasing
almost immediately and has continued to
decrease since then with brief spikes
when a new
you know what a new mm-hmm why do you
why do you think you're
not the country why do you think they're
so resistant
what
i think that they have an aversion to
going backwards
i think they will try every avenue
of uh of something new
first before they will go back to
something old i think they are
very very much as a company in favor of
what they consider
innovation and i think that it takes
a lot for them to turn around and say no
this isn't working we need to go back to
a way that worked in the past
uh i saw that when with first segment
i'm sure
yeah when i went there for the community
summit which was before oh yeah
right oh it was spooky back there that
was a that must have been a spicy summit
continue
yeah and basically the thing that we had
was like we were flat out telling them
like you need to go back to random roles
you need to go back to a
you know primary special heavy system
like what you're doing now
isn't working it was a contentious
community because we were flat out
telling them
your innovation was wrong that game is
less enjoyable
go back to this old system and until
they were credited they did
but we had a lot of discussions about
well what if we did this what if we did
this what if we did this and what it
came down to in the end
and they did find a better system right
it's a mix and match it's better
yeah but what it came down to was we
said it doesn't matter what you do
but what we had before needs to be a
part of it so
they were able to innovate and to their
credit the
weapon system we have now the perk
system we have now they're better than
what we had in d1
yeah absolutely i would agree that and
they're trying to do something similar
with trials
right i just it just
but work this is the thing that kills me
and it's just like
we would have to agree that was the
pinnacle
of the mode right so it ju
this particular i get where you're going
you're just explaining how they're
thinking i'm not coming at you
but it's just like i get with the whole
mindset of innovation
but the thing that drives me crazy is
this is you at your
height this is when your player base is
engaged this is
you're making money like people are
streaming
try like like i just don't get that like
that's the part that
really i struggle with and i get about
innovative because i'll never forget
when they made the announcement and
they're like yeah we're going to do it
we're not going to bring trials back
and people were like but why don't you
just make it however oh we you know we
don't fee
they made a statement it really i forgot
exactly it rubbed me the wrong you know
what statement october it rubbed me the
wrong way it was kind of like
you know well we're not going to go back
to that we're like why
like that that's exactly you at your
best at the at the most fun of the game
and
that was the only thing i struggle with
them you know what i'm saying but now
that you're explaining it
at least you're helping me understand
why they do the thing they do
which is like oh we need to innovate and
we're not going to take something
exactly the way it was and
and bring it back the way you know it's
just uh well i mean
i was going to say you and i cognito
literally when trials got launched
and the requirements to get into trials
we called it that night
we were sitting there like hey and now
you're like okay how are you gonna
combat cheaters you're like
i don't honestly care if i have to get
like a thousand kills in crucible and do
like a 10 hour quest
make it something you guys work towards
and that's your like that's your access
card
so like people can't sit there and
switch accounts and ban and cheat and
stuff like that
now there's some people who might but
then if you go through that long of a
process and again
the cheating is a big one maybe the
physics host that they're changing to is
going to help them
you know analyze gameplay and stuff on a
little better i know that's something
they're working on with the new big
download that we're going to get in like
two days which is crazy
um but that's one of those things like
between the cheating and then
the system we have now it's a truck
it's it's really unfortunate where
trials is at
unfortunately yeah evp
yeah they i mean they want stuff to be
like this is the problem with pvp
and all games are running into it now
but like the pvp portion basically has
to be free to play
for like people to engage with it for
you to have the population
need to support it basically has to be
free to play yeah so if they make trials
you know pay to play meaning you have to
have the season well then that
immediately kills a portion of the
population from like being part of the
place so they can't do that
even if it would keep cheaters out for
the most part but it's like
secondarily if you make the quest to get
into trials too difficult or too time
consuming
then you lose a lot of the casual
players and the thing about trials is i
know that
elite players want to think the trials
is for them it's not it's like trials
should be easy for you as an only player
trials is for
the not elite player to make them feel
like they're elite when they get
something done
like that's what it's there for and
if you lock the casual players out the
trials playlist when it's just a lead
player sucks
like right now it's really not fun and
it won't ever be fun again the trials
playlist needs to be made for casual
players and elite players don't want to
hear that they want to hear that they're
getting an in-game tournament blah blah
blah blah that's not what charles did
that's never what
like it just isn't unfortunately like
trials should be easy for elite players
because their elite they should just
blow through and get their seven wins
and carry someone else and keep doing it
right like that's what makes it good
but then the casual player you know
johnny 0.90 is like
i have a chance like i can do this if i
play enough if i play 20 cards a weekend
with my buddies like there's a chance
that i get there and that should be an
honest chance and right now they don't
have it so and not only do they not have
it but they're not rewarded even if they
were to try
they're not rewarding right so it's like
charles is going to continue to falter
until they make a change
no you're right i just why you got to be
johnny
johnny 0.9
i think the fallout is rubbing off on
you from firing range because that
sounds 100 that sounds like johnny
johnny johnny thumbs or whatever
yeah i actually heard that from datto a
while back when data was doing one of
the interviews he was like giant two
thumbs and saying miss me with the
spreadsheets bro and i was like why are
you calling me out
i love that valid stuff man i could talk
to stuff with work all day man this is
good stuff
but yeah i mean that's tuesday it's it's
not even two days away
we have 9 p.m for me at least central
time when the servers are actually gonna
go down
going to pop back up at 11 we got 14
hours of downtime
seriously how hype are you guys right
now i'm honestly just curious
i'm still man like if i wasn't working
from home i would have taken off like
probably the entire week to just like
play it you know like i love
i just love a new content release like
honestly i'm most hyped about
short term like about the story because
we so we so rarely get these like actual
epic
space western space opera type things
in destiny but every time we have
they're phenomenal
and you know it's literally it's like
every other year every other year we get
a day's worth of just really awesome
cinematic story content
and i so much look forward to that
because i do follow the lore
actually like kind of a lot like i you
know although this whole clove spray
thing
i have not kept up with because i had i
had a bachelor party and then i had a
wedding
to go to so i have like had zero time to
be like drunk all weekend
yeah a significant portion of it but
like i'm i'm gonna catch up on the clove
spray stuff and i'm
super stoked about that but like i just
love i just love the good wholesome
destiny story especially now that this
is totally unrelated like mandalorian
has like
given me like space western itch and
like
the deep universe itch that
the only things that fulfill that for me
are star wars and destiny
and so like one of those is like at a
peak right now with how well it's doing
sequel movies notwithstanding but like
tv series i just rewatched clone wars i
just watched
rebels and like having that tie in with
the mandalorian
i'm like ready to get the destiny story
up to that same level oh he's ready yeah
i'm super stoked for that
nice what about you cognito what's
obviously the hype levels are high if
you guys are in this chat if you're
listening to this one at some point yeah
it's a big deal but what are you looking
forward to the most what's got you
peaked i know i could guess a couple
things but i mean where are you at
what else i mean right now i mean i'm in
the same thing as marcus like i didn't
pay too much attention to the arg thing
but i caught shout out to tassie i
caught his article caught me up to speed
a little bit
but um for me right now it's it is
deep stone crypt you know saying because
i i'm in that zone like how we're
forsaken was where
i know listen to the aramis stuff and
that looked great i'm excited
to see what's going to happen with i i'm
going to hate
because we all know it's like erebus you
just say air missile i'm like
she's going to be like six campaign
missions and i'm just going to be like
that's nice and we're going on
like ah anyway that is yeah we know it's
some boss territory
my main thing with that is the unholy
trinity's involvement
with that whole thing you know what i'm
saying but now
as this arg information has come out i'm
not going to lie to the
the the clovis break thing is exciting
me because i saw that little trailer
and i always like when destiny gets into
like this um
like the technical robotic enemies and
stuff like that like i really like
raptor machine for that reason oh i was
going to say i got siva's your
steve as your jam aesthetically
i've always felt rats and machine
especially when you going inside the
thing
like it's one of the best the coolest
looking aesthetics and
i love that raid for that you know what
i'm saying siva the whole computer stuff
so for me you know this whole clovis
bray and he's just so maniacal he's
treating his family and he's making them
yeah like you know and he was always a
mystery to me i didn't really pay too
much attention
you know but now we're linking the exo
stranger we're linking anna
you know all this coming together and
the idea that this
this could be a raid boss like i could
there's some things in my mind like how
cool this could be so
i'm actually excited for the raid now
now i'm like yo
i can't wait to step in there i want to
know about the exos
you know i want to know about this whole
consciousness the wiping thing
maybe we get a little cane law stuck in
there in between you know we find a
little you know that'll be cool a little
nugget
you know about kate past life but um
yeah like the lore stuff
is really exciting me and obviously you
know the the unholy shield what happens
with them at the end of this campaign
yeah like to me
the the the best parts of destiny is
obviously the start
and then the end because you want to
know what's going to bridge into the
next story
and i love that kind of stuff so
ultimately that's it to be honest i'm
not
i should be more hyped about stasis than
i i was in the beginning
but now like the lore and the story got
me now so now i'm i'm in man
that's where i'm at right now how about
you man uh for me
uh i was like dakota said one of them
honestly the fact that
was mentioned at all in the la vida
related to this trilogy and she's like
one of the three proto-hive gods of all
i mean we knocked out one savithun we
know
is very much either the centerpiece of
which queen
and we're sitting here now getting a
season that's tied into her sister
and i'm sitting there wondering so we're
gonna have corrupted hive we're going
back to the dreaming city which is
always gorgeous
the trailer and the dreaming city looks
like
the big giant tower something is
happening in that sky box because you go
in there now that tower looks
pretty calm and there's a frame in the
trailer i was probably streaming it when
somebody pointed it out and i'm like
yep those aren't the same there's like
some big like radiating energy out from
it there
so i mean the fact that we're starting
now which also leads
gives a little credence to the fact that
aramis isn't going to be nearly as heavy
of
you know as they advertise her to be
sadly uh
but but the fact that we're starting now
with zebra wrath
savithu's place in the dominoes and
that's what they said it's like
uh i can't remember who it was justin
truman i think he's like
she's placing the dominoes and then
you know in the witch queen we get to
see what she does like when she starts
to kick him over or something like that
and just the fact that we're setting
this stuff up and savathun's always been
theoretically like this big i mean oryx
was huge and as you said
every two years we get these big giant
cool stories
awesome forsaken taken king and now
beyond light
and we get one of those savithoon seems
like out of place in that timing like
every two years
so but lightfall is that lightfall is
that one timing-wise that seems like
what's going to happen there and that's
where
the timing of this getting into
savithoon and i think knowing in my mind
that something is past savathune
really has me intrigued honestly is the
fact that they've hopefully set
something up awesome
to see where that goes because sabathune
being as big as an important she is with
the loop of the dreaming city and the
death battery and all that stuff going
on
and to know there's something beyond her
i think
that's going to be a really cool journey
to go through and the fact that this is
really
the start of all of that i'm excited i
hope that
i'm hopeful that they break the every
other year cycle and then now that they
have given us this like
we have a three year plan we have a big
content release coming your year i hope
that each one of these
is a new like cinematic thing because it
would be a shame to have sabbath come
and like
not bring a big cinematic story piece
along with it but
it feels like you know destiny was like
ever expanding in terms of like its
storylines like
literally up until i feel like this year
they just kept adding like more
and more and more storylines and finally
it feels like they're like you know what
i think we have enough story lines
let's start bringing some of these to a
close like let's start bringing these
back together let's start directing this
towards
what i imagine would be a conclusion
potentially not for the destiny series
but
for this age in destiny like
let's wrap this stuff up let's bring
back the exo stranger let's bring back
eris let's bring
you know let's bring all this stuff
together and let's move forward instead
of continuing to
unravel more threads yeah i mean that's
that's huge
the spaghetti code of stories all
dangling out there as you said and we're
finally getting to see
heiress who got introduced to us in when
did she have taken
or literally created chronicles i mean
it was
three months into year one we got to see
her now six years later
she's out on a completely different
planet messing with darkness powers
while she's out there and we're like
okay we got some stuff going on
yeah and i don't think you can
understate like how
impressive it has been that this
franchise has introduced so many
characters which now feel like they're
iconic to us right like i don't know
that anybody suspected that eris was
going to end up being
one of the favorite characters in the
franchise
that people were going to care as much
even about kade and the vanguard who are
very stereotypical archetype heroes
right
like the jester the magician the stoic
you know guy like they were all very
stereotypical and
then we ended up caring a lot about
those characters then they added more
characters
that we also care a lot about we care a
lot about the drifter we care a lot oh
yeah
stranger like heiress is literally
people love aerys like mara solve people
love like shacks
who just yells at us doing pvp matches
like
backstory though is so intriguing and
it's so exciting and like
people care about these characters like
they cared about oryx
who was a villain but you understood his
motivations
and like the the lore building that
they've done
coming from vanilla destiny which had
almost nothing
like it was basically empty with the
exception of the grimoire
and then to get to the point we're at
now where there's almost like story
overload if you're willing to look for
it
and there's so many characters that we
care about as players it's kind of
amazing to me like i don't know if i can
speak highly enough for the writing team
or the narrative team
bungie that has done this oh yeah no
it's like
i mean dakota said it in chat too when
you say all the stories coming together
i i lost my mind
just because i never expected to see it
when aldrin was
shown like dakota's literally saying
she's like she still gets a kick out of
watching my reaction because i'm like
who is it he's kicked over and he's
coming out of the shower shadows and i'm
just like
literally doing the arms in the air as
aldrin's coming out and i was like
i've had the debate with myself i was
like i lost it there but if i was
actually playing with my hands on
would it have been even cooler and in my
mind yes but i also know it's for
marketing so that's a debate i'll leave
but the fact that now we're getting you
know it's been two years since forsaken
in the dreaming city and we shot the guy
pulled pork i think i said pork chop
yeah
i said pork chop in my video and i got
crap for that so it's pulled back i shot
the poke shot though
yeah i was in the right you know meat
department at least
and then him and potentially everybody
was always like is he going to be the
hunter vanguard could that even be
feasible
and then what about marisov and all
these things and it's just like as you
said when you go deep into the story
there's a lot going on right now
and you as you keep we all have our name
for them i come like you know the ante
or the shadow vanguard basically
you have the trifecta but they're the
opposite of anything basically good
you've got
basically a crook somebody who's
basically traded her soul to like the
darkness halfway
and then a time traveling exo who
doesn't even have a
who has a fish i want the fish but
that's the whole thing
that's like one of the coolest ghosts
because it's like waves oh dude i want
that thing so bad
hopefully we at least get a name for
that so i'm curious but we have this now
trio
they're all on europa like this is our
next we're gonna have a social space for
a little one but
they're all going to have their places
out there hanging out they're all going
to have their own quests involved with
this
and potentially they're going to have
their different motivations and one of
the biggest ones for
the stranger as we go full circle and
look at my statue that i got of her is
like
we thought she was gone that we'd never
seen anything and the fact that we're
bringing her back
and the fact that we get to see her like
see her a little bit in action
fighting with stasis going cloaking and
she's just like
all of these three are i will say the
drifter of the three
in the trailer kind of got shafted and
how he looks because
eris is out there basically like
spinning and doing the wall and she's
like rolling the ball on her arm and
then
strangers jumping over kicking and like
cloaking and
i swear the drifter's about three
seconds from dying every time you see
him in all those places
he's getting saved by everyone else yeah
he's getting saved and he's like
all right thanks ladies needed that one
and i was like i want to see where these
three go and i'm like i'm
very curious to see how all of this
plays out though just watch it because i
have
never seen aris move she's a story
personally
she talks and now she's like hunter like
dodge stabbing like doing the
like she looked so cool so like no they
were the
the trailer my hype when i was watching
some of that stuff like if those who
watched it with me
i lost my mind a couple of times which
is always fun and exciting to do to see
characters that as
mark said like we've known them for so
long
and now we actually really get some good
interaction with them now that we're
invested it's even better
i can't wait i mean that that's what
it's about this was about seeing what
these threads that they brought back
seeing how they now mix them up and and
seeing what his goals you know i'm
saying
there's got to be some conclusions to
some
i feel because there's a lot there's a
lot so some stuff got to happen that's
so get ready man i think lance reddick
kind of was like
people are going to get blown away you
know for when he's doing a lot of his
voice acting and what's about to happen
and like i said y'all know i'm the big
osiris fanboy so i was just surprised
even though he got slapped to the floor
with the life alert i was i was
surprised to see
old man that's iris yeah they give my
man dirty man they did them
they were shoelaces together dammit they
did them dirty they were saying but
it was at the express of aldrin i'm
about aldrin i was i was glad to see him
you know come out there but again i was
surprised i wasn't expecting to see
osiris i'll be honest i was like
what is he's usually associated you know
specifically with the vag so to see him
associated with the
what is it the hive oh you know us or
whatever they did the chick name
is eva there you go to see him
associated with hive and i'm just like
okay this
again where is this going like so many
threads he's
talking with zavala he's he's messing
with what's happening it's i can't wait
i mean we have
two sets of stories because you'll have
aldrin
potentially with osiris who's now oh by
the way there's the whole thing with
osiris and zavala talking to cabal
that's still don't know what the hell is
happening there
but you have aldrin and spider you have
whatever's going on the season
that's like a pretty solid set of
characters
and then we have the main campaign like
that's more story than i feel like we've
had in a long time
a long time like four seconds and
continued into the dreaming city which
was awesome but i was like i feel like
this season
is probably one of the like it seems
like it's got a lot of potential if they
like deliver on it
so it feels like the avengers there's so
many people so many things going on it's
end games
but yeah but like start getting closer
like start traveling in that direction
and then you'll assemble
next year exactly it's gotta happen at
some point so
yep but yeah i wanted to ask you guys
too is like i mean we're getting a bunch
of lore stuff but the other thing we're
getting is something we've literally not
had since destiny started
art solar and void for six years now we
have a fourth
we have subclasses that are working in
different ways we have weapons and
elemental shields and all of those
things
i honestly wanted to kind of get your
takes on for one you mark especially
like
i we've had some speculation of what the
sandbox is to be like honestly curious
how
what state you think the sandbox is
going to be in that exclusive
anything from stasis but it's like i
want to start with you there just to see
how you think the sandbox is going to
fare with stasis
i mean i think i share the same concerns
everybody does we're basically having to
trust that bungie is not going to
introduce mechanics that literally make
the game not fun to play like nobody
likes being frozen in place
in a high mobility pvp game right like
just flat out and all fun nobody likes
being slowed down nobody likes being
disoriented like
those are things that are not fun to
play against right from the trailers
it made it look like those things would
be
common but those trailers are designed
to showcase the effects and the
abilities and things like that so
i mean i share the same concerns as
everyone else um i think that bungie has
enough experience to know better
than to introduce aspects of the
gameplay that are
not like tremendously
unfun to play against but then i look at
the supers in their current state and i
think how tremendously unfun those are
but
you know those you get two or three a
game right yeah you know you you don't
it's not a melee
it's not uh necessarily a grenade that
makes you feel that effect so it doesn't
wonders whether it'll be like the only
way if you get frozen as if the attack
would have killed you anyways and then
it freezes you
right so it's like well if he had just
punched you know it was an old male you
were going to die
now you just get frozen instead of dying
right so
yeah pardon me wonders or if there's
like a secondary trigger like you have
to be slowed and then you can be frozen
or you have to be direct hit by the
melee like with a hunter's waiting
throwing knife
where it's like you know so there are a
lot of ways that it could be done
i think it's really really interesting
i'm very much excited to play
as the new uh as the new hunter
because the ability to shift instead of
dodging is i think i'm going to be right
up my alley
yeah that's terrifying so that combined
with the fact that there's
the aspect that allows you to slow down
enemies when you
shift near them so it's like uh i think
that will be for me
so you think you might take to that
[Laughter]
does that play into your uh bastion
style though or is that more of like a
shotgun feel for you
no it will it will 100 because yeah if i
can
uh if i can shift and vanish
and then immediately appear next to
someone with my bastion
and have it charged yeah like i will uh
i will very much enjoy that
or if you can dodge the first shotgun
shot or something like that yeah it will
allow me to close distances a lot easier
which you still have to do with bastian
to a certain extent you have to do it
more with a shotgun but
even with bastion like i use right now
the dodge
or the shade step on my nightstalker
with bastian extremely effectively so i
feel like this is just going to be a
much stronger version of that
mercury is the raid boss of iron banner
careful everybody watch out december 8th
do not play where are you playing so i
know where not to be
xbox okay cool i won't be
[Laughter]
i'll see you december 8th sir you know
what's funny actually december 8th is
when the next gen patch comes
i didn't know that those two actually
falled on the same fell on the same day
no that that's what i see him december
yeah that's what i'm going for
uh higher frames per second and i'll
have a field of view slider
and i'll get to pair that with my super
high light level uh
you know bastion shifting hunter that
slows you down when it shifts next to
you
yeah so do you
think with the i can't remember the name
of the hunter one is that the
revenant i think no that's the
is that the warlock or is that i think
that's the luck with shadebringer and
then behemoth and then revenue but he
missed and then revenue yeah no i was
thinking of the exotic that lets you
teleport
oh the the mask
of backrest that's it i don't look it up
um so
and then the slowing dodge is subclass
because it's a
fragment no it's an aspect right so
you're going to be able to
do you think because it basically it's
based on a dodge do you think
like you're going to basically be able
to slow teleport
if you put those together i would think
so
i mean uh we've never seen something
that changes dodge this dramatically
yeah yeah but i would think it would be
a pretty big oversight if
equipping an exotic then disabled an
aspect that you had equipped
yeah right like i would think that
fundamentally from a
game from a ux experience that would not
make a ton of sense
so i would think that anything that
triggers off of a dodge
will still trigger off of shift
yep that's terrifying yeah that that
that's pretty scary
i'm just gonna go but i'm still gonna
take a bastion you're gonna go through
my over shield anyway but i'm still
gonna have an overshield on fly
hopefully
uh what about it looks really fun that
one looks interesting i'll be kind of
curious how that plays in a pve setting
as well to be like
save your butt now i can run and not be
stuck behind this that's the thing about
the
the wall is like one little portion in
front of you but if anything gets around
the backside now i just have a shield
and i can go find cover like the
survivability
of that one alone is gonna be better
than just about anything else honestly
i've been playing a lot of well of
radiance warlock right now and kind of
getting used to that right because you
got the healing grenade
yeah so people i guess don't really
think about the fact that like that
healing grenade gives you an overshield
so you just consume it and immediately
throw it in front of you and you grant
yourself an overshield like that right
and with the right build you can have
that up easily as fast as the titans
classified
so many times yeah it's funny it's funny
you said that
i can just go into an engagement and get
an overshield and that
basically guarantees me a win on that
first engagement or mid engagement i can
duck behind cover pop the overshoot come
back out with an overshield so
yeah it's huge i mean you'll be
utilizing i've been playing a ton now
it's been double rewards weeks so i've
been
playing a ton of pve nightfalls and
stuff and i've been using exclusive
yeah uh middletree man it is
really a great support class it it truly
is even with the nerfs to phoenix
protocol
i mean you really feel strong i'm
getting those blessings the divine
protection
then i still have the rift on standby
when i want to you know and it's
it's powerful man so i'm i'm just
excited to see
what stasis is going to bring as far as
all the uh what's what's those things
called the fragments sort of fragile
like class based and then aspects are
going to be universal to everybody
i'm very curious to see how that plays
out you know for the warlock aspect
the freezing rift is interesting oh that
one's got potential for pve written
all over it especially if you do a
healing freezing or if you pause them
you get your health back take care of
what's in range
and then potentially now you can remove
yourself from that situation
that's a survivable like there's
definitely i see some places where like
me being a solar player is how i usually
think of all that stuff is like as a
solo player in a pinch those moments
where you need that
the time to like get out of a crappy
situation there seems like some good
ways with stasis
everybody's gonna have the wall grenade
i'm really curious to see how that thing
breaks the game
like mobile cover everywhere
oh i need to get from this side to this
side because i'm getting rest over there
chunk that thing and if you can get
behind that wall to get a res depending
on how much health those walls have
i'm being it's oh man some of this stuff
seems like it's going to be a game
changer i'm honestly wondering
how much the other classes are still
going to be
viable yeah i was like how what is the
usage of subclasses i know they're
newer and the other ones are still fun
but these seem i know crowd control
related as opposed to like dps so in pve
i could see
but the potential of all these as you
guys were saying in pvp
they sound like they've definitely got a
lot of options for pvp
i feel like the old subclasses uh the
first thing that's happened they need to
be updated to the new
system that the new subclasses are going
to use fragments and aspects right like
we've been stuck for far too long on
these ridiculous
you know tree clusters where you pick
from one of three options which i
understand
why they did that it dramatically eases
the burden
of subclass balance but at the same time
it's not nearly as fun from a player
perspective
talk about not be able to mix and match
right so what i would like to see
even just to bring the new subclasses to
this new system
split that stuff out say okay you're
going to be able to pick two fragments
and then
a certain number of aspects based on
what fragments you pick which i'm not
i'm not sure if you guys um caught that
in the thing but the actual the number
of aspects you get is dependent on which
fragments you've chosen which is a
really interesting balance
way to balance those things as well
right so it's cool i think they need to
do that to all the old subclasses i
think if they just did that to the old
subglasses they probably have to do some
balance
like you know they probably have to
figure out how they want to turn stuff
into fragments or aspects or whatever
but i think that'd be huge
for the old subclasses as it stands i
think they're going to see almost no use
in the beginnings of beyond light like i
i think it will be
a cold day in hell when you see a
gunslinger out in the wild but
that's how it is with the new toy i mean
it's kind of like you know it reminds me
of
e would take a king drop you know you
had that celebrate
versus tickle fingers are you kidding me
for you like that's not even a contest
though and it's almost still not in pve
but
yeah i mean just from but it just
reminds me like when the new subclasses
came out and how everyone just
gravitates towards it
you're touching that new thing and it
takes a while you know before the old
stuff got touched so
you know yeah you would hope that at
some point they do a rework to kind of
you know i'm not going to say they can't
complete because we have to see them
tested but the old ones can't complete
but
it it this stasis stuff just sounds so
transformative that
you're just like yo you can't wait to
see what this thing's going to do yeah
it's just kind of a different feel too
for the game because a lot of things we
do have are very very
offensive minus maybe two or three
like we have some we have a little bit
of crowd control
between you have the bubble for a little
safety of the well for a little safety
the only real crowd control honestly is
tether most of the time
this feels so much of a different style
of play i guess is the best way i can
phrase that
so both in pvp for like the control of
the walls and the slowing things down
and the for pve
again walls for cover for res's and you
know
freezing things and just the crowd
control
feel of all the stasis subclasses i
think is something to a level we haven't
seen yet and i think i'm very curious to
see how
just how the subclasses all feel because
everything does feel throwing hammers
and kamehameha and
a bunch of throwing knives and nova bomb
it's all very
offensive as all as opposed to um
basically enemy management is the best
way i can say it and it's just gonna
feel a little bit different
so overall like stasis seems very cool
generally very exciting see how broken
it is
we about to see are you about to see
yeah hopefully hopefully not
too broken that would not be fun if
those abilities are like
because i don't know like running into
the slow minds that like the phone
yeah you're telling me that it's gonna
be like that times a million and it's
gonna be in pvp then i'm gonna be a very
unhappy camper unless i'm the one
with other one has to hope all i'm
hoping is is
if we play remember e we was in our
anthem bag
like detonated primer kind of deal i was
like i
maybe but honestly the way it feels is
like
they can't just slow us off rip
like you get a grenade out and you're
slowed like how would that
not work that and then you have a hunter
bounce a
ninja star which is the wrong word i
know there's a better version for it
sure i can yeah yeah
um and they bounce it off a wall and if
that's got decent tracking and you know
they're around the corner
my you're slowed you can't move you're
like oh no let me
like you're just slow-mo running through
molasses but now it's in game and it's
not on xbox so
slasher it's playstation 2 console
molasses i guess what you mean but yeah
i got i got you bro um
pc master race guys feeling himself hey
now everybody's going to get there so
can't wait for cross play with which one
so that'll be fun
i hope never honestly like i don't ever
want cross play
between oh it's going to deal with what
you guys have to deal with on pc
keep that cheating over there i was like
we do have a couple changes coming
though i mean yeah
they've talked about sandbox gambits i'm
actually curious keep forgetting gambit
is going to kind of get a revamp i'll be
curious to see what that feels like
because
i'm sure there's going to be a weekly
challenge at some point that gets me in
there so i kind of wonder what that's
going to feel like
with stasis as well like you go over
there and then on the other side you're
just doing
random spaces freezing gambit was a cool
experiment
i honestly think it's probably time for
gambit to like
go away it was a really cool experiment
it was super neat it showed that they
can mix the pve and pvp aspects of it
and have it function relatively well
like i don't know that anybody
thought that you would be able to do the
the portion of the game where there's an
invader active yeah that's cool you have
an invader you have enemy pve you have
enemy pvp it's a really
interesting thing i would love to see
them work more on that
into like a bigger scale maybe like
badlands that are a
social area where the you know pvp and
pve
is both turned on right like i would
love to see something like that but
to me gambit always felt like an
experiment
it didn't feel like it was necessarily a
game mode that was meant to become i
know they said that they wanted it to
but it didn't feel to me like it was a
game mode that was meant to become like
the third arm
of like strikes pvp gaming like to me
strikes in pvp are forever gambit seemed
like this was a
cool idea i think it's run its course
now
if you removed gamut from the game i
don't know that we would
lose a ton in the grand scheme of things
yeah i mean you can't argue with it i
mean right now as far as um
where gambit is obviously they need to
consolidate
the mode and obviously it looks like
what prime's gonna be the one the victor
so um yeah modified prime pretty much
yeah
did we speak to uh what is his name
what's his name
yeah homie from yeah yeah back then and
you know we're getting some feedback
from him on what need to go
you know i did like the the the whole um
what is it the uh the team based
mechanic and then you had you know
sentry and this and that
the problem is to me the mistake was
always putting it in a separate mode
to force you to play that mode to get a
suit that's going to be effective
in gamut problems so the reckoning
gambit prime
thing didn't never never work for me i
think they got a chance to
to bring it back i mean the maps are
gonna you know have to be played but
the question is do they have enough
resources of time right now is it that
much of a priority right now for them
to do it that's how i look at it to me
yeah
i don't exactly just say where you
shaking it i just don't think it's
on the bucket list so sadly
it's just not gonna get addressing like
you said i wouldn't
put it this way if they would have made
the announcement
when the dcv was announced that gambit
was going into dcv i don't think people
would have went
too crazy i've been too sad about it you
know
not that i want it to go away but i'm
just like that's just where gambit is
right now i know their hopes were higher
but they really got to make an
investment to
completely changing and adding some new
mechanics to the mode or the suits or
whatever
to make us care because right now i just
i don't it's i'm only in there if i'm
forced to be
or what you know what have you i'm not
really messing around outside of strikes
and
yeah crucible my infamy is higher than i
thought it was let's just say that
when i went to go like be like hey what
do i need to check out for the end of
the game looking at gamble and i'm like
wow
did not know i played that i don't even
know why i played that much this season
i think it's just been a long season
and i've like tripped through it
occasionally but no i mean gambit is one
of those
i would be here's a question for you
guys quick answer which one's in a worse
spot gambit or trials
trials trials yeah and then it's on a
bad spot it just yeah
but but that right there is like as many
people don't like gambit that tells you
the level of what's up with trials like
that's how much work it needs as
important as that
is to the crucible pillar of like the
two and then you have the
step pillar in there in the middle but i
was like the level of trials is that's
just a question i had but
we have like so there's going to be a
lot changing and there's going to be
some massive patch notes at some point
we get to read
we're going to get like a kiosk for like
lost quest which is cool and we actually
as all players get to go meet shaw han
fast and furious himself
uh i'm actually just kind of curious to
explore the cosmodrome
on pc whole field view high fidelity
like all that stuff is going to be kind
of beautiful especially for like
next-gen consoles you get to see it on
your 4k
oled and you're like i get to see 4k
cosmodrome
like that's going to be kind of cool so
i'm kind of excited for that but the one
i want to ask you guys about is
the monument to lost light's exotic
archive which is a mouthful in itself
sitting in the middle of the vault
um so they're going to be basically zur
is going to have exotic ciphers as a
quest that you can do kind of on a
weekly basis but the bigger question is
the currency spoils of conquest which
you get by
rating which we don't know how often
you're going to be able to get them or
how hard they're going to be able to get
but you know your raid exotics from
previous raids say
anarchies and terra buzz and all that
stuff
potentially going to be sitting right in
there for
purchase now that's ready to copy i was
curious what you thought about that
i mean i'm happy for people who haven't
gotten them so far
like i think that the raid system
uh for exotics that they have right now
is inadequate
i think it doesn't sufficiently motivate
people it's better now that they've
uh given like the the chance of getting
increases every time you do a completion
right yep
it should have been like that from the
beginning yes um personally
i know that as a player i'm not a pve
centric player
asking me to do one raid once
is reasonable asking me to do it two to
three times
is less likely but still possible asking
me to do it more than three times it's
not happening
almost zero percent chance so if you're
telling me that
like my favorite raids have been the one
where it was like you have a
quest that culminates with you doing the
raid once and that grants you the rate
exotic
and then if you want the ornament for it
that comes from beating on hard mode or
something like that blah blah blah blah
but to get the raid exotic yourself it's
a quest that you do you do the raid once
to me that's honestly the best system
for getting people
in the door to do the raid and then
making a cosmetic something that's
either a random chance or comes from
beating it flawless or country meaning
it hard but i think that's a better
system so
for me the raids are going away anyways
i'm personally of the opinion i don't
necessarily agree with the destiny
content vault although i understand why
they're doing it
i personally am of the opinion that the
more stuff there is in the game
the more chance you have of hooking
someone who is a new player
or a returning player a last player
something like that
so the fact that they will at least be
able to get these exotics that maybe the
first time they were playing they didn't
think they had a chance to get these
exotics
and you never know maybe tara buzz the
gun that makes somebody fall in love
with a game
right yeah like that's the stuff that to
me like i'm glad that
they're doing it this way although i
know some people would be like i
did this right a hundred times so i get
this weapon and now you can just get it
with an exotic circle it's like well
you know sucks bro you shouldn't have
played the raid 100 times like
everybody wants this stuff to be like
exclusive and like in my personal
opinion exclusive stuff is not good for
the game unless it's tournament
ornamental exclusives are fine i don't
have any problem with that
but gameplay exclusives i don't think
are good i
think locking away really cool weapons
behind potentially
50 plus raid completions is crazy
bad ux design in my opinion spicy take
bear
cognito do you have an opinion or yes i
do
arguments
[Music]
no but i understand merck's point in
reference to
like i understand it it's wrong but i
understand
i understand that in reference to
repetition
i do agree with him that there's those
things that raid protection should have
been in place right
where the more you run it and shout the
black iron man and check that's my guy
because i want to shout them out
because the thing is to me my main issue
is the damn catalyst what's happening
those are worse
but let's get back on track now what
this whole thing is
listen i i do like the idea of
raid exotics and i do like the idea of
rarity i do like that stuff
you know it's just to me if the drop
rates will improve so that you don't
have to run it a zillion times
then i think it would be less of an
issue i just think the way they started
out the gate
and they just never really improved upon
it but i just
i agree with the ornament stuff i i like
that aspect i like the aspect of having
that
i think like call of duty does it or you
know you have this either the amount of
times you do it or
the difficulty that you do it that you
get this exclusive skin
but i do like the idea of of things tied
to endgame activity because
at the end of the day it's like again we
just got to be careful i always feel
like we have to be careful that i always
use d2 vanilla
as the example like you know when we get
into that
thing of the casual kind of getting
everything
you know what i'm saying the incentive i
feel wears off to even go back and let's
be real bungie wants you to play these
activities
i know it may be considered artificial
to keep getting you to run in there
but they want you to play this activity
and the last point i make is that to me
it's a travesty that i consider i know
your pvp but i consider raids
like pinnacle endgame content in gaming
like a destiny raid when done right
is few things in my opinion from a
cooperative experience that match it
and i just love things tied to it
the balance just comes from having
them do it in a fair manner where yeah
you're not running
a thousand times you know i'm saying
you're never going to get a terrible and
you're never going to get a 1k
that's ridiculous i i completely agree
and the other problem i think
to me the more bigger problem i think we
talked about it e
is the fact that it shouldn't just
always down tie down to the exotic
like how about making these legendaries
better how about making oh my god
you were you're still in my point but
absolutely yeah yeah like
give us more reasons to run it so that
it's just not this
singular item and then it just won't
seem so egregious if we had those like
we said
numerous you know last word progress you
know weapons and armor that tied to
mechanics of the raid or
just things that are really
intrinsically unique with perks that you
could only find from the raid weapon
then it's like okay i'm in this i could
get a chance to get all these cool
things
and then run it consistently that that's
where i'm at with
yeah i mean i'm probably split between
both of you guys
uh the timing is key like i mean what is
it i know destin legary had to run aunt
for anarchy
like 60 some odd times i saw somebody do
a cross stitch with a hundred and plus
like so i was like those are ridiculous
and that shouldn't be that way
no kidding the idea of a quest i like
that as a way to get
newer players maybe not have a raid but
hey this quest pops up okay now you need
to raid and be like where's that
incentive well you've got that quest log
staring at you be like
maybe i do go look at lg maybe i try
these raid things to
go after that one thing that i'm missing
and i know if i finish it i'm going to
get it
now the way they did kind of leviathan
was cool because they had
legend of accuracy you got the first
version
and then you go back and you can work on
updating it maybe that's a way to kind
of give you incentive as well which was
really cool you got the basic function
yeah and you got to improve it but also
on your side too it's like
i'm honestly very worried about the raid
mods
because either the cost because now you
have
five slots on armor we still only have
10
energy to work with and say we're gonna
have now
all the regular mods are gonna be
enhanced but they're gonna be called
regular but they're gonna function as
enhanced
say you take the cost of a grenade
launcher
scavenger or something or reloader and
that's
four and then say you go intellect and
that's two
that's literally two and i have three
other slots that i can barely even use
at that point and you're still trying to
build a loadout around that it's like if
the ratings
the raid mods personally probably and
hopefully are like
zero i'm sure they're saying yeah it's
like they need to be zero just so you
can have a function to use those things
because if they take points away from
trying to get a normal build in there
then you don't give yourself a chance to
experiment with that stuff i agree but
it's like i mean i've said this before
too is like i want
and this is the same thing it was like
it'd be nice to see trials have this and
then like grand masters raids kind of a
couple places where you can get armor
that had
more energy say it was like you know the
trials armor had 12 energy like they had
a depth trials armor that you could get
because right now if you guys have every
other week it's going to be trials
weapons or adept weapons in the chest
but when it's an armor week who's going
to play especially if it's the same set
of armor
for the next two like season or two that
we're gonna be stuck with for a little
while
the armor if you don't have it already
there's very little incentive to get
that
because they don't have anything really
setting it apart right now
um but if there was at least energy that
had you know 12 energy and you could
use a few more mods you could experiment
with it more and it gave you more
customization to your build
but not to a point where you could
probably break it yeah
i mean and that's one of those things i
know they have like the heavy finishers
like seven
because it makes it just out of reach so
people can't like have that and
something else on there which i get
and that's one of those things i guess
they watch which heavy finishers still
usually never with the bang for buck
because it's half your damn super yeah
it's just so much um
but just like the the
the raid exotic quests like i like that
idea but i'm also with you cognitos the
fact that the raids need to have
legendaries that have unique perks that
something to set them apart because if
it is just the quest and you're done
there's still very little incentive to
go in there that's the one time thing
for merck and that may be all he wants
but if he's like
hey there are raids in here that have
unique perks and there's trials weapons
with unique perks
that's why people are going to play
things on a continual basis and stay in
the activities
right and that's the biggest thing i
think they need to work on because right
now the legendaries
you can get almost the same stuff from a
public event and that's just kind of
what sucks
and final point to me like i said i
think the reason why
raids like vaulted glass and rather
machine work is because
you had this tremendous pool of these
great
weapons to farm at each checkpoint and
each
you know what i'm saying so it made it
tied it to one kind of yo it's a chance
i can get
you know the the the one that had triple
double and you know what i'm saying at
rats and machine and all these schools
and then obviously we had the
ultimate one with outbreak you know
prime you know as a
super secret and stuff like that like
when raids are done
well there's rewards at each stage
and the entire process becomes so
incentivized and i think rap does it the
best and that's not even my number one
raid but it's my number one
reward way because remember when you got
in there you got to see the keys
and even if you ran it for the week and
you got the rewards hey you help
somebody out you still got a couple of
keys
you can combine that and you can get a
chest and get a reward again
back to mercury's point which is why
when they have something that works so
good do they feel the need to say
no we're not gonna do it anymore like i
don't like wrath of the machine's reward
system
was amazing i i never ran
raids more even though vault is my heart
i have to admit i ran raps
so many times because the reward system
and the weapons were so
good and they got to get back to it man
they just they can't they got to break
out of this mentality we
have to you know revolutionize all the
time like come on you got the system
some things work there's a lot they need
to understand like i don't think they
even understand their own reward system
like inherently in terms of what they
offer right like you have
so many avenues in the game that you can
give to players right you have
avenues actually really only like one
avenue that directly affects the way or
plays minute to minute which is weapons
right
you should not ever hold weapons behind
something that is extraordinarily
difficult to accomplish because that
alienates a large portion of the player
base it's
in incapable of accomplishing that thing
right and it leads to resentment in the
player base
and it does a bad job of motivating
people to go into difficult content if
they don't feel that weapons
are achievable right however you've got
armor which for the most
part is aesthetic although now it has
stat rolls and stuff on it but for the
most part you can build your armor the
way you want your armor right
so you've got armor you've got armor
ornaments you've got weapon ornaments
you've got emblems
you've got shaders you've got emotes
right
you have sparrows you have ships you
have all these other things that for the
most part
don't actually really affect gameplay
right there's so many avenues to reward
players
for doing hard content with exclusive
stuff that
the player who's not good looking at the
player who's got that
really really cool uh ornament on their
gun or that glowing
cape that's an ornament for going
forward ornaments like the wings yeah
they were it was such a great idea and
they've backed off from that too and
it's like that's how you reward players
you know why because the player who's
looking at him
doesn't think oh that's so unfair that
that player has that and i don't
have it because it's just for show it's
just for appearances they're just
growling right
and you look at it like ornaments for a
gun or an ornament for you to brag to
yourself or if you're streaming to brag
to your viewers
right yeah armor and armor ornaments are
bragging to other people in the game
with you
an emblem a ship is bragging to other
people who are in the game with your
sparrows bragging for yourself right
like you can
you can target these types of what do
you want a player to be bragging about
right like
they go flawless they need to be
bragging to everyone so you give them
arnold ornaments right
if you go flawless in a raid you want
them to be able to brag to themselves so
you give them a weapon ornament right
like you can
target this type of reward to a player
without
holding weapons hostage behind running a
raid 20 times which
you know only like 10 of players do
rates anyways right the amount of
players who do a raid 20 times or the
amount of players who do a raid multiple
times
is very very small right and when you
say like
look you have a one out of 50 chance to
get anarchy
well players even like myself that are
hardcore players like
i'm not doing that like that's not about
it even if even if i could get it my
first time which i could i'm still not
gonna do it because it's just not worth
it right so
but if you say we guarantee you anarchy
the first time you run this raid
every player who gets that quest and has
the ability to is going to do the raid
once which gets them in the door
then you say in order to get anarchy's
catalyst you do the raid three times or
you do the raid on hard mode
in order to get anarchy's ornament you
do the raid flawless right or you do the
raid on a speed run
in order to get the ornament for your
armor you you know it's
there are so many avenues that they
could go to to reward the player
and they haven't quite figured that out
yet and also unfortunately
a lot of those avenues come through
eververse which is a way
to like reward players because like i
remember i was uh
i was playing destiny and someone
messaging me was like dude that's that
[ __ ] is so sick where'd you get i was
like everybody
yeah not go play this content and knock
it out here
not like go do this thing right like
ghost shells exotic ghost shells in my
opinion
i understand having exotics that are
like tied to events like festival the
lost and
you know the summer stuff like i
understand that right those are
specifically made for those events and
that's it but like
in my opinion exotic ghost shells should
be given as in-game rewards for quests
that you did for story missions that you
did like for stuff that you did
you should pick them up for my quora
most of the exotic ships you should get
from amanda they should be given to you
for completing triumphs and stuff like
that so that when someone says where did
you get that [ __ ]
you can say oh man i had to do this i
had to go and i had to kill
200 000 forsaken on the forehead and
shore or something like that right like
it was crazy and then that gives someone
something to do when you say like oh i
bought it from every verse it's like
yeah you know i spent
six bucks on this [ __ ] but like the
other person was like oh i don't want to
spend six bucks on it and they just like
pull it off right
i was like no first that's been i've
used pitt of heresy for
apparently about well i guess the past
year now feels like it's been out longer
but no it's like when i went through a
bit of heresy working on it i soloed it
first and you're like
honestly that's like what you said it's
like you solo you start to get
you know some armor ornaments or
something like that and then maybe if
you solo flawless it you get something
and they did some of that stuff with
prophecy
a little bit there's a ghost there's a
sparrow but like
also the same thing thematic things like
i got the same armor from doing
a solo prophecy run that i did from
doing an heiress
essence and i'm just going i wanted to
look like zolmak like you give me zolmak
armor i walk through the tower looking
like a fire hive night
i'm gonna be the envy of everybody and
then if my
then if it kind of just looks kind of
like lava at first but then if it's like
old school end of d1 glowing armor if i
get solo ornaments or something from
doing that like now i've done it five
times and i start to earn those
yeah people like okay what'd you do it's
like well i soloed
this thing five times and then the solo
flawless gives me like uh you know halo
abomet who knows but like
that was a prime example because the
ship that was in the next season that i
got from eververse
fit the thematic like shadow keep stuff
so
much and i was like oh and it bugs me
and i was like and i used it for a
little while but i was just like
this should have totally been in there
totally and i'm sorry
no go ahead that's the pit of heresy
yeah so everything you said
is completely encompassed in just all my
experiences a bit of heresy they got a
little better with prophecy but still
not quite no i completely agree i think
for me
where the epitome of it the epitome of
the realization of all of this what
you're saying
is i've put off the whisper of the worm
catalyst
until the very last week of this season
and each week it required me to go in
there
and as a warlock face my fears as being
the worst jumper
going right so i had to face my fears
and i had to get a gun
and i got it done you know what i'm
saying but the thing about it was
coming out of that exotic quest when you
did the void
you did the ark you did the solar and
you get that ship
it's a badge of honor it is now i
put that on because i know people didn't
do that there's a good percentage of
people that didn't do it
and it's like peacock system look
peacock said joe like look at me like
you that's destiny that to me is where
they need to go back and i don't
understand
look i understand they need to monetize
their business they need to make money i
get it
but things like what you're saying pit
of heresy that [ __ ] that you're talking
about what do we know
should have been a reward in for doing
it whether it be solo or whatever
it may be they need to get back to that
and and that's that balance right now i
know
this these last couple of twelves
they've been talking about getting back
to that
and i i feel confident that they will
because that's that's the end
best the same thing like merck said you
go into the tower you see that guys with
the trials on them and you're like whoa
what is that like
i want to get that and and armor is fair
enough right
it's not where it's giving that person
this advantage right but it
it's like yo this is a badge of honor he
look at the peacock that just passed
wow that was amazing he's trying like i
gotta get in there i gotta get that
that's what it's dope man but yeah i
really realized it
now that i got my whisper to where i'm
done and i'm rocking that
you know that's old ship and i got the
the little aura around me i'm like yeah
i put that working
yeah yeah absolutely that's a great
feeling and like they don't embrace that
for a lot of other activities so
we have a ton of stuff in every verse
but like yep i don't know the last time
somebody bought a legendary ghost shell
from everest like
they're pointless right they don't no
you don't you don't even look at that
thing that much when you open it in the
first place
much less spending money on it now that
one's yeah it's like you take a game
like path of exile
uh my buddy played it and it's free crap
load of content in there like
a just metric ton okay that's gonna
change the podcast a bit um
uh but that's one of those where those
like skins that look like
god tear looking armor you're like you
look absolutely amazing
those skins are like 30 it's free though
and there's hundreds of hours in that
game that they can do and that's like
that's how you choose to support that
this is a game with expansions
now seasons that you've got to buy and
all those things that you put in
and if that stuff's not in most of the
game i understand hey they can put some
cool stuff in eververse
maybe things like your iron banner emote
that you're like i gotta have it
but there should definitely be a lot
more stuff to earn and i'm hoping as you
said they continue to embrace the idea
of
putting stuff in the game to earn that's
where
a lot of it should be to keep people
playing because if you see
something cosmetic and as you said merc
i bought it that ruins it for a lot of
people really fast
absolutely so you know the iron banner
email you know
we talked this about them when we were
there but they were like oh well the
iron man emo
like that should be an in-game reward
right like that shouldn't be
a you're about to get some entertainment
continue you're about to get some free
entertainment
shout out who put the sit up for e
oh they put over the chat it's on now
fitness time
fitness we're just not ready for this
we're at the last word here we believe
in fitness and thanks for redeeming
those 5 000 push-ups we're all sitting
out here
with the covent belly we're trapped in
our houses and you can't work out
but you got ibottus and lord cognito
give look at that perfect form
elbows hitting the knees burke is like
what's happening what podcast did i join
you joined the last word ladies and
gentlemen
this is what we do out here we're
getting there yeah
they land they're killing them right now
people are sitting on points to make e
do exercises
this is amazing that's a good that's a
good use of points i feel like
oh you felt the bernie we felt the burn
brother
working up a sweat while podcasting
that's good
see and the best thing is i never know
what he says because i don't listen to
it and i can't hear you
it's great i do to play my play with you
out there because i knew burke didn't
know what the hell was going on right
now
he's like what is happening his face was
classic
yeah they use these points man oh they
make they use the voice but
continue work out interesting we had to
get our fitness segment in i don't even
remember what i was talking about
yeah i was i was like oh yeah those are
some nice looking sit-ups right there
all right
good job but yeah we even told him we
were like look man like
if it's iron banner themed you should be
able to get it from iron banner
like you should be selling that stuff in
everburst because it
it's like themed to iron banner which is
an in-game activity like sure make it a
really hard quest and i remember
or i said even do this sell one in
eververse that's one color
and then make one that you can only get
the request an iron man that's another
color right
so can you see someone doing the green
version of the email you know they got
that [ __ ] from a quest
yellow version of email you know that
they paid money for it right like even
do something like that but don't
just stick it in everywhere and they
were like well
when you make something attainable
in game there's this weird mental thing
that people have
where if something is attainable in game
even if they will not attain it they
won't buy it
from yeah right even if they won't get
it they still won't buy it in the nem
store
and they said like that's a really hard
thing you have to deal with like they
know for a fact
that even though the players would like
it more if it was attainable through an
in-game quest
such a significantly smaller number of
players would buy it from the store then
it basically is no longer worth it to
even put in the store
right and then because it's an emote
they wouldn't do the work making that
emo if it wasn't going to go into the
store
right like they aren't going to build
that email for iron banner because iron
banner's not making them any money it
costs money
so they're like our choices are don't
make the emote at all
and we don't make any more money or make
the emote
and put it in the store and put it in
game in which case we lose money and it
wasn't worth making the emote
or make the emo and put it in the store
so at least then people can buy it
and like you know and they're like
that's the honest truth and i was like
well
honestly the best solution is like don't
make emotes that are focused on iron
banner and stuff like that
like yeah you know making emotes that
are
playing guitar or like playing the drums
or something yeah just continue to do
that because nobody complains about
those not being available again
yeah and those aren't a big deal but
what was it the uh whisper of the worm
you had the
two ornaments for whisper that ended up
paying for what was it zero hour or
something like that that happened that
way
and that's the thing hey this cool thing
that you can go earn it's a big deal
everybody on the
world of destiny is talking about this
quest then when you go get cool quest
now you can customize that thing to look
a couple of different ways and that's
one of those that they said ended up
panned for it that way and they haven't
done that in a while they've done it a
couple times
but they have only done only a few
exotic quests anyway but they haven't
done those that are
and as you said what if like there was
the raid exotic you go do that
and then you turn around can you know
buy a couple emotes
and that quest took them into the raid
then took them to the eververse and
that's like
feels like you get people in more
activities and into the store it's kind
of a double win
potentially but i know there's somewhere
in that equation that it's a lot harder
than i'm making it sound
i know that mm-hmm no i don't agree i
agree brother
i was like i know we've kept you for a
while i know four yeah we got more
yeah i was like i know for most of the
sandbox changes like everybody's looked
over them
for me the biggest one i saw was like
the anti-champion mods
seem quite exciting for the armor to
give that shift over and i'll just kind
of be curious how that's implemented out
but
as we're wrapping up i know there's
stuff coming to the store that looks
really cool
i know the down time is going to be like
14 hours i want to ask you guys two
things one
are you doing anything kind of unique
for your down time 14 hours you could
just be sleeping for all i know
and then two um just kind of your last
is there any like surprise or any final
want for beyond light that you may not
have seen yet that you
hope to be surprised by
i don't know if there's anything that
i'm like hoping to be surprised by
kind of just hoping like the release
goes smooth and it's
good fun and it's a good story and like
it gets people hooked i mean the
population has been really really low
this is probably the hardest
destiny has ever been challenged
population wise in its existence
it doesn't help that split across three
platforms now instead of two
but also there's just a ton of really
great games out there right now
like a ton of good games um it's a great
time to be a gamer
but it's a bad time to be trying to
bring people back in
with an expansion that's already been
delayed so i just really want to see
everything go well i want to see
people come back to the game i want to
see you know players that haven't played
a little bit turn it back on i want to
see new players players coming in from
game pass like
i want to see destiny you know crush it
again for a nice little bit and i want
to see
things go so smoothly that those people
stick around and they play because the
game's best when there's more people
playing it so
absolutely brother i'm with you man i'm
with you and i gotta get i
thought yeah well xbox that that's a big
deal i think with the um
with the game pass i know we talked
being he has talked about it yeah i'm in
the same boat i mean
new expansion man the stuff the fall
expansion is always where it's at
you know for me i love it you get the
most content the biggest type of story
beats
all that stuff i know we didn't talk
about it briefly but um
these anti-champion mods on armor y'all
all about that you know and that is
gonna open up exciting
opportunities for exotic use exactly
and i can't wait that man i got dust i
got my i'm glad i got my catalyst done
for outbreak perfected
you know it it's so many things i can't
wait to just
not be pigeonholed into a legendary
and forced to only have the mod for that
legendary to use barrier or whatever it
is and
it's going to give flexibility we're
going to see some fun combos
i was actually surprised they didn't eat
because you know i thought they were
going to try to play us safe
knowing that we'll put together some fun
combinations for these nightfalls
i've literally been saying it for a year
i'm like all you are is breaking if
you're
if your exotic weapon was already
balanced where you think it should be
the only thing you're doing is allowing
people to use it against exotics
and they took that away for about a year
and then honestly the big thing is now
the fact that like
theoretically if what graviton lance is
always an example if that's a balanced
gun
in their mind if you give me the option
and now use that as an unstoppable
all you're letting me do is use it as an
unstoppable everything else functions
the same but now i can actually use that
as an option i'm not forced to go right
basically just use a heavy exotic
because that's the only one's not a
champion
yeah anti-champion mods are going to be
fun i have to ask mark this question
though
do you think bert cause this is where it
gets a little
i i gotta be a little pro developer here
but i wanted to see
what your thought is do you think with
this
change that ariana's vow
leviathan's breath exotics that have
already intrinsic champion
anti-champion perks on them
will also be allowed to have that
additional one
based on the the armor stuff the mods go
anti-champion mods also going on armor
two birds with one stone there will
ariana's valve be able to do
anti-barrier and overload if you spec it
um i would think that no i would think
that they would remove that
and they would put it on um yeah
i would think that for the sake of
balance that they would remove that
just functionality from all the exotics
that happen right like
not all the exotics have it already so
it would actually kind of be more
uniform
and more expected of a functionality
that way
now that's additional development work
right so
maybe they just decided to screw it
we'll just let ariana's valve we'll let
leviathan's breath like we'll just let
him do too who cares right like
what's the worst that could happen
someone enjoys using an exotic a little
bit more than they were gonna enjoy it
before like it's probably not gonna
break the game
so you know they might just say yeah
whatever screw up some these things get
a bonus
but i would think balance wise that it
would be
better if they did remove it because
then all exotics are back on an even
footing which is really where they
should have been to
begin with and the alternative is giving
all exotics one of those
you know behaviors by default and that's
the most work
so i definitely don't think they're
gonna do that so follow-up question
do you think it was a mistake or the
right
direction to push exotics into having
anti-champion perks in general
i i think it was a mistake but that's
because
i don't think that the anti-champion
i don't necessarily know that i enjoy
the champion
mechanic in the game i can vouch for
that
yeah yeah you guys okay okay i know i
literally
just got done going through conquer and
i can honestly tell you like
yeah you can set up in sync for it but
the unstoppable i'm most okay with
because that's a point where you have an
aggressive enemy
changes the mechanic behind them
and they also don't get their health
back which is one of the biggest things
infinite healing oh
the barrier like if you're not literally
as soon as you see the animation start
it's almost like dark souls you got to
see the animation start and be ready for
that shield to pop
instantly get that barrier shot on there
or that health goes
so fast
and that's one of those like i would
love to see them change the way
champions function or i mean also the
fact that the health regenerates cannot
tell you how much that pisses me off if
i have to break a shield again
that's fine but if you break a shield
you hang there for a second and you get
your health back
that's why i like seeing somebody like
esoteric solo it is like
the timing has to be so perfect
constantly keeping damage and it's just
like
it drains your ammo that's the biggest
thing so no it does
the the champions themselves since
they've been implemented
the unstoppable i like it takes an enemy
that might kind of be roman or like an
ogre that's shooting
and the dude starts running you gotta
stop venus tracks so it's like that's
theoretically kind of that's a different
one but as you stop them health slowly
works its way down
even though they get that so it's like
that one i can kind of understand but
the other two overload's just about as
bad
because if you don't overload them right
and they're still running at you and you
don't have the overload ammo and they
get their health back it's the health
coming back up
in an activity where it's already hard
enough to manage everything else you
shouldn't be penalized just to try and
survive what is already chaos
couldn't continue working you definitely
spock something for me
i think sorry champions are the
a little bit the worst of both worlds
right like they if you don't have the
correct mod they're almost impossible to
kill
and if you do have the correct mod
they're relatively easy to kill to the
point where
it's like oh that didn't add anything to
my gameplay other than forcing me to use
a particular loadout
right which i don't like because i think
part of the fun of destiny is building a
loadout that works for me
uh to defeat a particular challenge and
i don't think being told that i have to
use a hand cannon because it has armor
piercing on it or unstoppable
it's really fun for me so i don't like
anything that
limits my loadout by force i like
figuring out a loadout because i've
played the encounter
and then picking a loadout that works so
my preference would be
that things like armor piercing just
worked against enemies that were already
in the game
like the hobgoblins when they shield
themselves or like the knights when they
shield themselves like
i would just like if armor piercing
worked against that naturally i would
like if
unstoppable just worked against more
aggressive enemies and
like stuff like that like i think that
they could have
made it to where champions were easier
to kill without those mods
so the mods didn't feel like a flat out
requirement
but then you know the mods wouldn't be
as important i mean i just
personally i think it was just one more
wrench into like i think they're just
like throwing stuff at the wall like
when we had war mine mods and charged
with light mods and like
at this point i think they're just
throwing stuff at the wall and they're
like trying to see what sticks
and in my opinion it's cluttering the
pve
sandbox to a pretty significant amount
where we're starting to get a lot of
like extraneous stuff to where like
i'm pretty involved in the game and
even sometimes i'm like wait what what
am i supposed to be doing here like what
is
going on in this particular thing like
there's there's just a lot there's like
a sensory
overload and there's a loadout overload
where you're like i have to have this
and this and this and this this and this
and this
and then when you have all that it's
like it doesn't even matter anyways
because it just you know you just
breathe through stuff but
so i think that uh from a mechanic
perspective i kind of wish that they
would just do away with champions
like in general and i hope that this is
either the beginning of them phasing it
out by removing it from all the weapons
and making an armor thing and then
slowly starting to drop it out
like the same way they're probably going
to do with the war mine stuff like i
don't expect the war mine cells to be in
here for
all eternity right like i think that was
a one-time thing they tried it they're
like
i don't know about this let's phase it
out right charge flight it seems like
it's here to stay at least for a little
bit yeah charging around that's fun
to me i think charge lights are really
interesting mechanic i finally
started to i'm sorry you know the charge
with light doesn't ever feel like a
necessity
charge of light only ever feels like it
enhances your gameplay experience if you
feel like specking into it if you don't
i don't feel like it takes anything away
from you
if you don't equip a champion mod you're
gonna get slapped in the face
by one of those champions and you're
gonna lose whatever engagement you're in
because you can't beat it or it's very
difficult to beat it i don't like stuff
like that very much
i agree i know you're making valid
points but i i was i wanted to pick your
brain on that
because i i definitely understand your
mindset there
being locked into those type of moles
and like you said it's funny you said
charged with light because
that's what i finally dug into the last
it's been sitting around for a while
but i finally committed and i was like
all right let me mess around
and the builds are fun man especially
i've got a survivability build with that
what is it the um it's a it's a void
one it's protective light yep so like
the more charged with light you have
i mean it's a get out of jail free card
in certain situations you can get
lashed and your energy killed and you're
still alive for about 14
10 seconds it's giving you this little
health buff um
supercharged it's super underrated to
let you stack bore
obviously we don't even need to talk
about loosen blade right i mean loosen
blade is
it's out here you know what i'm saying
so yeah like
charged with light is really that power
by the way
look at that yeah charge of power now
you know
but um yeah it's it's really it's really
important so i can't wait
you know to to see where else they go
with it
and i do agree with you with your last
point where i think that the world mind
excels was more experimental that was
more with figuring out what we're doing
with this thing
kind of deal i know one of them was like
pick up and throw and other stuff
but yeah i think charter likes kind of
way leaning towards and i do like that
those are touch lights great that's how
all stuff like that's how master working
and everything like that should be
like you should be able to get a base
version of some functionality which you
can play the game at and then for those
people who care
there should be a deeper level that
provides you with a small benefit but a
noticeable benefit
but not enough to where if you don't do
it you can't complete something right
like i don't like that type of
exclusivity but
go charge with light because i you know
like you
i ignored it for the first couple
seasons it was out it was kind of dumb
thought it was kind of pointless didn't
really care
started realizing that like how much i
could do with high energy fire and pvp
which is a double stack of rampage 100
of the time you have it up just for
picking up
serious well turns out it makes ariana's
about one shot
uh turns out it makes le monarch one
shot turns out that it makes
bygones two bursts like it's a high
impact the swipe that has a faster rate
of fire
so now it's a staple in in gameplay for
me and i
make a point to make sure that every
armor loadout i have has all my charge
of light mods on it that i want from pvp
and i go around picking up orbs i use
all masterwork weapons so if i get lucky
and i get a double kill it generates an
orb
it's it's a whole different ball game
for
me but at the same time like if i had
never
known about charge of light i'd still be
playing the game and i'd still be doing
just fine on my own so
yeah that's the type of bonuses that i
like to see i actually like what they're
doing with the adept weapons
where the adept weapons get some
slightly different mods that are stat
bonuses where the master working at a
depth weapon gives you more stats
across the board like i like that
because
an adept weapon is not going to you know
be a game changer over a rival version
of that weapon but for people who care
about men maxing it's going to be
like you know i'll go get it because
why would it it's not going to hurt me
to have more stats on everything like
i'll make it a little bit better
but a casual player is not going to look
at my gun and and
think oh his gun is so much better than
mine because he has three more stability
and three more handling right like it's
not gonna work that way but
you know for me for someone who maxes
everything that i possibly can like
yeah that's going to be great for me
yeah but the champions are just kind of
the opposite of that
it's like you don't have a choice either
use this or die
or die because you won't get past the
mirror that's a good point that's good
and it forced yeah i was like
i mean that made ariana's to a point
like the
i can't tell you did six grand masters
ariana's was involved for
most of them if barriers in there it's
ariana's because you have the range
you have the amount of shots that you
need and they never get specials in
there and that's the only one that's
kind of special
and it hits hard enough to matter but i
mean if you had barrier on a sniper
rifle why the hell not
every barrier typically is going to be a
long range enemy anyway
let me pop it with a sniper and then
turn around and fire and hit the crit
that already staggered like that's
it seems a little too obvious as opposed
to all let me do barriers with a
submachine gun
and then now they're going to be
barriers with a sword by the way a
chainsaw sword that's coming that's
going to let that's like okay so this is
high risk high reward
i know that's what it is but i'm like
dude grandmasters are tough enough if
you sneeze in the wrong direction you're
gonna die in there so
said it they said it dad said
[Laughter]
dad we can't stay in far distance
away picking away at things dad said we
can't stay in protective wells reloading
and melting things to death
dad doesn't like it okay so that's very
good that's totally fine
here's the difference when they say
don't do that
don't make something so artificially
difficult at 1100 where you're capped at
10.75 where if a
sniper looks at you wrong and you don't
catch one out of the corner of your eye
or they
i had an enemy head shut head peek me in
a grand master i was like dude it's
barely over wall i can't even see the
and i'm just dead and i'm like i didn't
even see the shot
that the lev the the artificial
difficulty is still something they've
crutched on since crota
and i still am not a fan of that in the
pve setting
contest is like to a point where they
want those things to be difficult like
and that's a temporary thing
but it's like when you and i made it
through like we did it all but it's just
like it's not
i wish they would work on more mechanics
as opposed to just
artificial punishment i guess that's
just me
they do they have modifiers underneath
the scenes
so and d1 they were explored you could
change the difficulty
normal heroic epic right or difficulties
and when you change those modifiers
the enemies shot faster shot more
accurately were more aggressive had more
health right like they were things
those still exist behind the scenes in
d2 right and they do get
turned up like you'll notice in gambit
on round one compared to round two
yeah it's because they flip that switch
basically in the background you can't
see it but it is happening and that
happens in grandmaster nightfalls too
the only reason they're using um
the only reason they're using light
level to do stuff like that is because
of the way they handle like enemy health
and enemy damage dealt
in the in the back end is more dependent
on
light level because they introduce that
as a mechanic on the player's side right
now
so like they could technically like
show you your light levels being even
and then
actually have the enemies like scaled
higher in the back end
but that's less transparent to the
player and it doesn't actually give
and then you would feel like it was
unfair that they were one-shotting you
but the problem is it's like
the ai in this game just isn't quite at
the same levels like what the ai was in
halo in terms of its abilities to like
do multiple
yeah things like take cover and
functionality yeah
they're much more like independent
little ai units and they don't
work tremendously well as parts of a
whole like they did in
in halo right i agree so in order to
make them
difficult for something like a grand
master they kind of have to keep you
scaled under
light level if they didn't if you were
at level it wouldn't really be very much
of a challenge and then it would be
because you would be tankier the enemies
would die faster like
there's only so much they can do with
making them smarter and shoot more
accurately
without them dealing more damage and
taking more damage
right not fair fair enough man
well man uh i think we've covered a lot
but i also want to make sure we respect
your time and let you get some sleep
because it's getting late for a couple
of you guys and me as well
um is there anything you guys else
wanted to
basically say before beyond light
because it's
36 hours away what i was gonna say is
i'm ready
new expansion you know i'm gonna deep
dive into that bad boy
lose my life two weeks of vacation i'm
ready let's go
live two weeks of vacation my boss knew
what time it was i said you know it's
destiny right
two consoles coming out beyond light
life is good man i'm good
um i'm jealous of that man i'm working
from home so i'm not even going to take
any pizza i'm just going to try to play
as much as i can
in between like meetings and everything
like that
see i've been doing it what i'm sorry i
should have been muted my bad
i've been i've been disabled i've been
doing it all year but i work from home
i'm like i gotta take this vacation
before i lose it
oh yeah uh but what about you mark it's
gonna be a good time i'm stoked for it i
just
i wanna play some good destiny i wanna
play with new subclasses i want to see
what new weapons there are i'm
excited about the new raid when it
finally drops like i'm excited about the
story i'm excited about
people coming back to my clan who
haven't been playing in a while because
you know
it's been a drought as far as this has
been the longest we've gone i feel like
in between content
or destiny i'm excited i'm excited for
the uh
for the end of season event or whatever
it is before they flip the switch and
turn the servers off or whatever that is
they said the
lights go out so i'm interested uh to
see how they're going to do that but
yeah 14 hours yeah so you've got
servers go down at 7 pm pacific i
believe
and there's a baby patch at 4.
yeah everybody's gonna kicked out get a
baby patch so i think
that is gonna either be like at about
405 when you log back in we're gonna
have an idea of like
hey join in the tower whatever this is
it's gonna be happening around that time
and they did it i think late enough in
the day they're going to hopefully give
people a chance to get off of work to
see it
yeah and then servers are going to go
down so and hopefully it doesn't last
for like
six hours
i think they got the feedback on that
one that it's gonna be slow
either it's gonna be a briefer
experience for sure
um but as we wrap up merc i wanna just
give you the floor
uh where they where everybody can find
you where
what you got going on where they can
expect to see you just
anything you got coming up uh let
everybody know because this is your time
to spread the word
amen uh i'm on the destiny massive
breakdowns podcast we record every
thursday night release friday morning
um that's me and my buddy kate cutcha we
pretty much talk about the destiny
sandbox
obviously we talk about current destiny
news but the real focus on the destiny
sandbox so
do weapon reviews you know uh anytime
new weapons come out we like to talk
about those
uh you can also find me on reddit
although not nearly as much because
unfortunately i don't have a ton of time
anymore but when i do i post on reddit
you can find my destiny massive
breakdowns weaponstat spreadsheet
uh if you google that you should be able
to find it pretty easily it's got all
the weapons on it and then
i'm also on the firing range podcast
which is every other wednesday that's
part of the destiny community podcast
family
and i'm actually going to be on dcp uh
this thursday stay with us thursday i
think it's
thursday i hope it's this thursday i
also got the date wrong it might be next
thursday but i'm also going to be on the
destiny community podcast as well as a
guest so
got all the stuff upcoming uh coinciding
with beyond life it's gonna be a busy
time but i'm looking forward to it
absolute pleasure like i said i wanted
to thank you for coming on and eve for
making this happen
you know what i'm saying few people are
fanboy mark was one of them like i told
you i guess i used to watch to read
that read it religiously like you know
like
i love that all the minutia with that
stuff excites me so
salute to you man keep doing what you're
doing love seeing you grow in the
community really
really cool man glad you came on dude i
appreciate that thank you guys for
having me i miss the fact that i don't
get to write on reddit as much but i
i stopped by crucible play with the
other day and dropped some knowledge on
someone who was talking about sniper
rifles without really knowing what was
going on
i get to school if you go to school i
was like i can't let this slide man this
person doesn't know what they're talking
about they've got like 300
votes and they got they're completely
pushing down some wrong information i
was like no i'm not going to have this
so
i still stop by from time to time and
you know i'm writing a little something
but yeah
because that intro comes with a little
research and i looked and i saw one i
was like
oh shut down like oh yeah you should you
need to send them to the burn unit man
because god that was
it was but it was just like it was so
tactfully done and
data and saw and everybody and i saw the
people be like yep thanks mark
there you are i hadn't seen you in a
little while there you go crushed it
like
the people know when you're there and i
was just like damn
yeah cause dudes are coming in with that
emotional
antidotal evidence acting like it's fact
and they're running with it and then
you see work coming that i'm like oh
you're about to bomb it with the facts
let me see what this is
i don't stand for that type of stuff
people get off on that all the time
they're like oh i feel like this i feel
like this is like let me explain to you
why you're wrong
here we go let me show you some stats
get a work
no absolutely man that's awesome that's
awesome
what about you cog what do you got or
what what just happened today for his
change of events
oh man what a day what a day double duty
today you know what i'm saying but um
salute to everybody that turned out man
we had a jason ronald the creator of the
uh
series x in series that's when i lost
podcast tremendous man learned a lot
this man
besides looking like a wizard with that
amazing beard he is a technical wizard
like he is a beast man salute to
everybody that came through
again i love podcasts every sunday 11
a.m eastern
you know and support and it was it was a
good turnout and we learned a lot about
these new systems machine learning
everything that's going on with ray
tracing and and everything that's
involved with these new consoles and
we're here man we're about a week away i
mean we're
actually a few days away i was like yeah
that's the same as that that was
two days that's beyond like pick up so
yeah so if you haven't catch it check it
out it's on the island podcast youtube
channel
you already know atla cognito on twitter
and of course please again support thank
you for the support for the website
lords of gaming.net a lot of positive
energy with the reviews and stuff and
people
you know sharing and retweeting the
articles and stuff like that and uh you
already know that last
word with my man ibotta's little sunday
night
campfire well worth it man a pleasure
and salute to you for doing your thing
man
seeing the outrider stuff just got to
get you to retweet your stuff more dude
we talked
about that that was a twitter glitch
making it visible now
scheduled out and everything match the
video this man's giving me a hard time
on self marketing right here it's fine
because you make he makes good content
and i'm just like well you got to give
me this you do retweet i like scream
well there's another one i gotta get on
but now you guys make rick i want to get
you guys out there more but yeah salute
to you man i see you moving god fall
outriders ambassador all the lunar
shooters let's go
um trying to be busy now like this
that's why i said like in the
introduction is like this past week has
been
a real life roller coaster and then i
think
it works fairly well but depending on if
you're a content creator or not
this next week is where hopefully a lot
of people can get
a nice distraction in the world of video
games with a lot of things coming a lot
of options between
assassin's creed miles morales sackboy
demon souls
godfall destiny and then cyberpunk comes
in december so if you managed to finish
eight other games you got big giant one
waiting for you then too so
there's a lot of stuff coming for me
tuesday's destiny wednesday's destiny
thursday is godfall in destiny
probably mixing those and then demon
souls i'll see how that fits into the
schedule but those are my three to start
with at least
i have hopefully at least one
ps5 showing up at my house in some way
or another i don't
don't trust anything until i get a
tracking number and basically it's in my
hands because the way it looks right now
until it's in your hands things on
reddit things on twitter seem to be like
a big maybe so hopefully that happens if
i get it in my hands i'll be playing it
but other than that
at least one yeah there's multiple
pre-orders but there's other people who
i'm helping if i get more than one
they're gonna go away pretty quick so
hey it was like you unfortunately was
like i don't even know if you get one of
those yet so
i'm saying there were other people
before dude mark do you got any openings
at the massive breakdown
do you got any openings because i'm not
getting any love here
hey i just wanted to know
i was like my brother's the priority
because the way he ordered his even
though i gave him crap about it i don't
know if his
is coming so my brother gets dibs stone
gets priority bro
that's why i was like depending on how
many show
that's why so it's like i just i threw
as many hats in the ring as i could
but yeah my brother gets priority over
you sadly yes he does
salute the stone salute that's the whole
that's the way all right you get a pass
hey
my nephews are like my biggest fans
anyway so i got to look out for him
wow it'd be your own people sometimes
cockney i know i know
i just you know i just show up here you
know well as you may have seen
um mark when we wrap this thing up i
kind of give the little outro
have a big pause and we'll try and say
the last word together don't wait on me
when you start saying it i'll catch you
through the joys of internet delays
so everybody you guys have been amazing
chat has been awesome this week
we got a lot to look forward to i don't
make any promises yet for a last word on
friday between cog and i would just be
the two of us we'll see if we get time
for it in between the chaos
but for today november 8th thank you
guys
um it's been awesome for this episode
it has been